oh
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
l'école est là qu on devait pourtant
allez-y là nous sommes heureux de ces
bus nous saigner
ceux concernant les années qui sont nos
deux que les jours sur le calendrier
[Musique]
rihanna nous a fait changer tous les
gains soleil se prend 2010 année le
compte pas il veut nous c'est finalement
toi même et touba et te voilà on vient
le chercher
ça vaut près tout raté
[Musique]
quand as tu ne dis pas ça pour faire
plaisir avec l'idh aussi bien il faut
être en france avec moi je le suis je le
jir
d'après toi tu dois marcher qui peut
être fière crois moi autant que je suis
c'est bon tu crois oui c'est faux
pourquoi toujours douté toi comme un
débutant parce que parce que je faisais
plus rien et puis je t'ai rencontrée tu
m'as rendu le goût l'ambition la
confiance et ce miracle c'est ton amour
un amour auquel je n'osais plus
pressants auxquels j'ai la folie de
croire parce que tu m'as fait coincer le
présent est aussi pour moi plus grand
mère et ma maison
elle te plaît ma maison elle y est les
charmantes tu aimerais vivre avec moi et
toi comme tu as bien du ca et toi tu
fais tout intimidé ce matin ouais c'est
la première fois que je viens ici tous
tout est nouveau pour moi tu penses que
tu t'habitues ray au dernier moment tu
n'as pas un regret là on est encore
temps de le dire je ne m'en voudra pas
pas l'ombre d'un petit sacrifice as tu
as vingt ans au mot pardon bougez pas je
vous en prie mais excusez moi d affaires
à personne ne m'a demandé à personne on
t'appellera j'attends cadeau à 6 la paix
téléphone et je lui dirai que c'est
d'accord pour ce soir 1 8h30 et sûr
terrasse comme d'habitude un oui et puis
tu lui diras tu pas pu soit charmant
j'ai en plus chez elle ça répondait pas
attendu par charlotte mais non non non
mais moi je l'appellerai et tais toi
qu'il appellera oui j'ai dit oui c'est
tout oui merci papa
quand on a besoin des enfants sont
jamais là et quand on les voudrait nous
dire vous a toujours sur le dos gd
fléchi ça m'étonnerait coire vie inutile
d'autant barras et charlotte tu diras
que tu es pas au courant je m'arrange
enfants atteints du support courant tout
arrangement oui ou alors tu veux dire
est que j'ai pu avoir que deux places tu
as bien compris un oui oui oui excusez
dérangement je vois que tu es occupé
mais vous suis allé chercher je me le
demande
il est au courant de projets elle le
soit aujourd'hui même sa soeur aussi est
amer et c'est en temps
ma mère est une adorable folle la seule
chose qu'elle me rapproche ce sera
d'être raisonnable je ne voulais surtout
pas que tu aies disant nuit ici à cause
de mon des hommes mais quel ennui
nous sommes libres l'un et l'autre nous
nous plaisons à sangles c'est vrai alors
y'a pas de problème pense que grâce à
toi le travail qu'un jeu d'enfant grâce
à toi je suis à nouveau dans la course
j'ai retrouvé le goût du combat
tout est neuf et la vie recommence une
miraculée jeu miracle je skie miraculé
c'est pas beau pour moi aussi un
collégien pourrais m'en vietti vésale
collégiale honoraires je fais un peu fou
alors disons nous sommes l'un et l'autre
raisonnable est maintenant finie nous
allons passer à l'action
nous nous marions le mois prochain et
nous filons sauf à visiter la villa
médicis où j'ai passé trois années de ma
vie
as tu verras on se perdra dans la nuit
du forum on descendra en calèche jusqu'à
saint pierre non on dînera en plein air
au milieu des églises dans les cloches
fonté corouge ensemble à cette
extraordinaire qu'on ira entendre aïda
baïda dans le cadre de caracalla les
thermes de caracalla l'ailé nuit romaine
elles sont à partie verra de ma vie
j'étais aussi locaux ou moins c'est
l'amour c'est l'amour à tous combien si
la vraie téléphone il vaut mieux qu'ils
m'appellent attendrir est tout bon
parent tapage et à peine entendus
ou alors tu diras passer prendre ici on
va dire ça sent fort plus eu à entendre
mais retient encore commencé dans prix
non mais c'est pas toi que je parle
ah bon on pouvait s'y tromper par don
cherry moi je croyais que c'était pour
moi j'y pensais ma mère à toi est au
courant elle sait que depuis quelques
mois ne sortons ensemble tu lui as dit
mais attention elle m'a répondu tu fais
faute à cause de mon âge bien sûr ah non
pas du tout mais de manière un homme
connu il te trouvera ce serait flatteur
parcours droits dits dont elle est
gentille pas mais nous adorons vous
faites avec l âge 38 ans on vous prendra
pour mes deux filles ou toi pour notre
grand frère aîné tout au plus pour le
grand frère de ma belle-mère ce sera
vous
j'oubliais maman va se remarier une
folie son fiancé beaucoup plus jeune
qu'elle
mon beau père il a terminé son service
militaire attend de lui qu'il soit jette
à l'eau
charmant contraire d'un jeune mère me
dire bonjour petit et son enfant de
marie ça va mon fiston son second enfant
de marie france à deux reprises et moi
je raconterai merci papa ça va ça va
didon papa tu prends la bagnole cet
après-midi mois en cfa mais si papa
savas avant tout celui là quel âge at-il
battant comme toi chérie je vais te
faire un aveu très grave je t'aime au
pardon
image peu près du seuil bonjour françois
maison marie noëlle où j'en essayé gado
il s'appelle cadeau un mot paix les
femmes adorent j'attends dans le jardin
tu attends quoi que tu es fini de lui
faire la cour mais j'en ai pour la vie
m'ont jetée l'asp est longue et heureuse
et à part ça fait contentons travail
avance j'aurai bientôt ta partition
samedi tu leur as un doublé dans la tête
et est en train de me descendre au bout
des doigts elle va finir par arriver
tu étais inquiet petit bras sur tu
faisais plus rien depuis cinq ans et ben
réjouis toi j'ai retrouvé la forme et
avec ça une interprète dont on parlera
des montants totaux des tu ne risques
rien à la lance et bien je le souhaite
cherchait précisément une bonne nouvelle
pour toi jackson me propose un thé un
talon dons pour l'automne tu peux signer
nous serons prêts nous serons prêts à
vous parler anglais et mademoiselle pas
très bien la dame elle le chante
adorablement tu seras genou elle a un
talent fou elle a même celui de m'en
donner c'est beaucoup dire
j'ai d'ailleurs aucun mérite je la
regarde elle est là et quand elle n'est
pas là c'est pareil je l'atteins je
l'espère elle arrive mais on s'en mêle
et toujours dacquois fait maintenant mon
petit cadeau je vais te confier un
secret tu les aimes tu as deviné
et c'est réciproque et c'est réciproque
monsieur cela vous et à moi de lui à
n'ont rien ne m'étonne je souhaite aux
célibataires endurcis twin aussi
merveilleuse aventure tu retrouves raté
20 ans mais il est de fait que te voilà
tout rajeuni françois et bien tu es ce
que tu attends qu on fait autant mais
l'amour on ne rencontre pas à chaque pas
heureusement on serait la surprise tient
à ce que tu vas écoute plutôt ça ouais
tu veux bien aidé non juste pour lui
donner une idée parce que tu ça paie
sous
tous les gosses n'est mais ce front row
2 les années du nombre de fois il nous
suffit d'un mot tendre mais que tout va
et te voilà
tour à tour
et toi mais chômage chez madame toujours
aussi à l'aise non mais vous dites ça
chaque semaine et pourquoi blême sa
chambre avec l'allument
voilà pour mettre des temps que ça dure
vous savez et nous espérons que vous
n'êtes pas au bout
mais point n'est au bout de quoi ben ali
dont françois et ben il est pas galant
ton ami cadeaux michel tu atteins fils
au tennis tout y est plus fort et la
conversation
aurais-je café c'est bien possible
excusez-moi mal mais excusez moi tu veux
me présenter un site adorables créatures
ma mère je suis enchantée madame merci
elle est tout à fait charmant si vous
êtes tout à fait charmante mais non
c'est quand ils veulent huit règles
votre fils me parle souvent de vous
madame mais en bien j'espère il m'a
raconté votre vie en détail dans les
détails des détails mais pour les porter
aux nues
dans tous les cas elle est très fière de
vous et comme je le comprends votre
visage et d'une telle des têtes tant
d'esprit il est de joie dans vos yeux
je dis tout ça très molle mais vous avez
beaucoup de charme madame elle me plaît
décidément beaucoup cette petite à toi
aussi
dieu que c'est beau d'être jeune et
aussi bientôt au salut pas mal non plus
de savoir vieillir sans regret sans
envie comme il se doit quand on l'a bien
vécu et c'est mon plat mademoiselle j'ai
autant de joie avoir autour de moi des
gens heureux
khalek moi même et d'ailleurs si j'étais
heureuse je ne suis pas trop malheureuse
grâce à toi mon fils chez drouot merci
et toi tu es toujours heureuse je suis
follement pas mis nos shows aux
madmoizelles un croyez vous il est beau
mon fils en vie
mais roddick j'étais jolie et j'ai la
faiblesse de ne pas protester mais vous
n'êtes encore elle me plaît décidément
beaucoup c'est fait
à toi aussi je parle dieu que c'est bon
d'être jeune et aussi bien tourné et
passer mais ça n'est pas mal des savoirs
vieillir aller sans regret et sans envie
comme il se doit quand on n'habite pas
vous raconter tennis mathieu ont été
appelés à venir noté alpha demoiselle
quand j'ai débuté au théâtre et un jaune
lors anglais m'a fait visiter l'école on
me cherche de glace à edimbourg
manchester la semaine où je sais tu es
beau qu'il était beau à général connu le
général bello jr et son nom lui vaut
toujours taire les noms à divorcer mais
miné sa façon à lui de dire minouche un
peu plus militaire et roche
mais les militaires ont parfois des
chars dans ce pays j'en ai fait
l'expérience
quand je fréquentais l'état major
j'adorerais si la cour
j'allais dire j'adore chez vous quand
même avec sony mais d'abord il fit sa
cette mère j'ai eu une bonne idée cette
nuit-là dire je crois bien que c'était
un ovni alors qu'on menait italien
maintenant je ne suis pas si
mademoiselle vous aimez les chansons au
pivot elles sont merveilleuses madar et
pied vous voyez tout à l'heure je vous
disais que je n'avais pas de regret est
cependant j'en ai un très grand regret
c'est celui de ne pas pouvoir les
chanter je suis mis en outre autonome on
pouvait pas y venir à 100 alors très
bien
eh ben je vais vous laisser maintenant
moi je me fais une confidence je peux tu
toi mais tu es mon ami avant tout je
suis même ta mère moi que par accident
tu as toujours été indulgente à mes
folies ben j'ai toujours été indulgente
à t phonie bas que jamais rien fait dont
tu vas t'asseoir mais pourquoi tu veux
toujours me faire asseoir mais les gens
ne sont pas ingrats dans la fin j'ai
fait la connaissance de mademoiselle
villiers il ya trois mois banalement au
cours d'une audition de distinguer entre
50 nous voyez quel jeune et tout est
très depuis qu'ils veulent c'est ce
qu'elle ne tombe dans les bras
nous sommes terrible dans la famille et
ses deux jolies filles s'est laissé
faire le pari regarde elle rougit
j'ai compris et comme tu es très
séduisant très gentil garçon
mais si tu lui a déclaré ton amour lui
vaut mieux que l'amour connais pas moi
tout cas pu bien
et peut-être chanter qu'elle était la
femme de tom en êtes-vous de votre roman
tu veux l'épouser maintenant vous voulez
bien madame ou mademoiselle ou penser le
jour de sa naissance
je me suis juré qu'ils seraient heureux
je ne vais tout de même pas renier mon
serment au terme du voyage
je vous regarde le noise elle vous êtes
tout à fait charmant vous voulez lui un
vrai morceau de roi
j'ai bon goût l'espère très 10 dont tu
la france est informé michel et martine
de de ton projet je veux bien non parce
que tu l'a peut-être oublié tu as deux
grands enfants
ils seront peut être moins conciliante
mois eux ils seront peut-être jaloux non
mais j'avais la ration de leur part les
remarques au bassin bouge pas c'est
parce que quand on a 20 ans et qui vous
tombent du ciel ou jeune mère de votre
arbre moselle il ya des précautions à
prendre
il faudra bien qu'ils s'habituent à me
dire non ces gens-là nous à l'appel à la
partie alors tu veux que je mets annonce
la vod jamais rien passé ça au dessert 1
nous avons placé je serai panache et
toutes ont tenu la petite martine que je
te présente ton père qu'est ce que je
raconte
je voulais dire prendrait ses agresseurs
vous êtes une jeune élève sur qui je
fonde le plus grand espoir et elle est
dotée d'une voix unie unique c'est
beaucoup dire
ab tout cela ne serait rien si lily
aussi sensible qu'intelligente
n'ajoutez assez dans ma conscience un
équilibre un ensemble de qualités
d'investis de pain de qualité de vie
tandis qu'il apporte tout naturellement
à envisager a souhaité même à désirer
c'est ton avis va mal c'est en ami ma
mère
pour me résumer lilly a toutes les
qualités d'une maîtresse de maison
je suis sûr qu'il le pourra être dans la
vie d'un homme un élément de stabilité
d'harmonie de lumière c'est bien c'est
bon c'est bien simple tu me rappelles
déroulède c'est pas super non nous
déjeunons à quelle heure ah bah c'est
toi qui situaient maîtresse et c'est
alors une heure bien d'autres en dire
c'est à dire que si ici j'ai pensé pas
nous pensons maman et moi que ce projet
est une excellente chose pour nous tous
ici tu vois là et que la présence ici de
mademoiselle villiers ne pourra
qu'apporter un petit complément de
lumière et de bonheur dont un foyer a
toujours besoin
ma mère c'est une nouvelle comme à nancy
c'est un avis qu'on me demande car en
vérité je ne sais pas de quoi il
retourne
je n'ai pas besoin de préciser les
papilles aucun calcul le président a
tout ça seul l'amour ou égal à nunavut
expliquera françois et moi nous
connaissons la question un simple
souhait pour terminer voilà c'est un
moment mieux même que c'est que chacun y
mette du sien joyeuse humeur bonnes
grâces compréhension surtout de parts et
d'autres
ainsi se trouve à régler dans la joie
générale le petit problème qui se pose
tu as compris martine très bien alors
tué ni marcher ni surprise se ferait
pourquoi serais-je pas chez ceux qui me
seront peut-être un peu c'est que michel
qu'il me cache rien mais jamais
confessant prochaine
ce n'est vraiment pas la peine de
répéter sur tous les tons le mariage
très peu pour moi dans dix ans on verra
fin je trouve jeunes un pédiatre ou même
ses études mais ceci dit je me réjouis
de son bonheur puisqu'il semble être
aussi tiens qu'est-ce qu'elles répondent
tous mes compliments mademoiselle vous
êtes d'ailleurs charmant vous ferez mon
frère et vous un très joli couple
et je ferai moi une belle soeur possible
tout en moi j'essaierai bon eh bien pour
le reste de jeune à une heure très
précises je suis seul aujourd'hui tenir
la maison
mademoiselle et démontre probablement
bien subi par des partenaires je le fais
si couvert c'est avec thérèse il ya des
jolies site rmc ça me dérange au non au
contraire dis moi tu pouvais pas mettre
au courant
moi de quoi donc et tu veux me présenter
papa rate mon fils michel
il fait sa médecine mollement s'apprête
au bout de trois ans a terminé sa
première année docteur tu te rends
compte parti sis à lui reprocher quoi la
boue l'amour dit non quand tu veut
surveiller un peu ton vocabulaire tu
sais si tu d'abattre excusez-moi baronne
on vous embarque au tennis il vous
embarque pas rentrer de mieux en mieux
avec va donc à traiter les femmes avec
un peu moins de désinvolture retrouver
car ça fait très carabas peut-être mais
nous sommes nous des artistes entraîné à
d'autres manières will go on et puis en
1902 jeu pour connu l'époque 1900 que
durera cet évêque c'est mon vieux pâte à
dents ou seulement combine 900 mon ami
on ne disait pas tout de go à une femme
on nous en parle et on leur envoyer des
cadeaux des fleurs consacré à l'amour
des soins que vous êtes sûrement pas
mieux de lui donner un jeune un peu
comme preuve que les jeunes femmes
d'aujourd'hui n'ont souvent d'autre
refuge et d'autres plaisirs que dans les
bras qu'on sait probablement mieux leur
ouvrir à mon argent tiens on vous en
verre par an mais je le sorte que tu ne
m'a même pas les 70 que présenter il y
sera demain vedette à l'opéra a
peut-être deux heures sûrement
je suis élève c'est un coeur va bien je
suis désolé d'avoir involontairement
causé cet accident et michel est très
sympathique et je vous assure que rien
de ce qu'il m'a dit de ma choquer bah
moi non plus je lui demande tout au plus
un peu de correction et de mesures dans
ce propos mais voyons j'aurais mal
compris moi il me semblait que michel
était à la veille d'être votre fiancée à
boire ah ah ah non de nomades mais elle
ne vous n'y êtes pas du tout mais tu as
tout du tout du tout du tout du tout dit
mais pourquoi le fait que je sois de
michel il n'y avait pas de situation
oui assez cela il ne s'agit pas de les
faire excusez moi et c'est pour bientôt
votre mariage mademoiselle il est beau
il est jeune il est riche le gars le le
pas non mais c'est insensé score
engagements ont-ils le chercher dans la
marine
1 les canaris jean les dates nationales
avec vous monchi riche avec les siens
avec les ans mademoiselle vous allez
faire un petit tour en classe
bon
bon vous le prendrez comme il vous
plaira de mou voilà je suis divorcée
depuis dix ans s'est passé je suis donc
libre
c'est le présent et je m'apprête à me
remarque c'est l'avenir c'est l'avenir
moi je souhaite que mon projet vous
agrée ou sur plus jamais pensé que
j'avais besoin de permission
je refais ma vie c'est tout ceci dit je
vous aime l'année lotos tendrement je
connais mes devoirs et j'entends de
cause aucun préjudice
mais vous vous mariez vous aussi un jour
à votre guise je me mettrai pas plus en
travers de vos folies et je vous
autorise à vous apporter aux miennes eux
si folle il ya pis et pousse tu t rès
notre voisine du régime oeuvre de 40 ans
as tu préfères des demoiselles gens te
croyait possible et qui sera ma mère que
cette question vous avez eu la jeune
fille qui était le voisin têtu puces de
mer sa mère jeune épouse elle est après
et après et après c'est uniquement une
affaire de moyens et un homme peut
toujours faire face s'il est bien
entraîné
murs poids pendant le main chez les
bulgares ces courants martine tu sais
mais le ch dont les bulgares tranquille
tu m'épouser cette jeune fille le mois
prochain il sera même françois le grand
et nous on sera les petits d'abord bien
non le crew lanka en ces temps l'état
croulant tu le veuilles ou non
oui j'ajoute que vous souhaiterez vite
conquis par la délicatesse et
d'intelligence le charme de vote sont
jeunes belles mères les oublieux des
détails d'un calendrier ce sans
importance où vous pourrez jouer avec
moi d'une décision qu'ils aient la
sagesse même et le bonheur en plus pour
tout le monde ici mais les folles les
mets ton père bon les miennes alors un
dernier conseil pas d'allusion à
l'exposition de 1900 autant des fiacres
des diligences et aux folies belle bar
vous pouvez disposer il c'est officiel
ton mariage officiel est irrévocable
avec ou sans permission
non avec one en moi c'est moi enfin si
vous même un tant soit peu réjouissez
vous de me savoir heureux on se sent 20
tours a jauni
que toi pour être franc vous pensez bien
que j'ai mesuré l'écart qui me sépare de
cette jeune femme et les dangers aussi
j'ai pas besoin de rappel à l'ordre
accordez-moi dont sportivement un petit
supplément de bonheur bon quand tu as
tout se règle sans combat singulier où
l'on votait mais les cons blanche porte
bien
c'est comme si ça les amuse tu m'étonnes
quel âge à elle comme nous 20 ans dans
dix ans la mort à trente huit doubles et
ben il en prendra le plus jeune pour se
consoler mais il faut l'empêcher michel
qu'est ce que tu veux si les mordus ont
tous un saint quentin bat c'est la
minute où tout commence quand ils ont
peur que tout soit fini
tu peux pas comprendre je peux pas
comprendre manon était jamais rien
arrivé il ya une cuisse
première nouvelle qu'est ce qui était
arrivé tu voudrais bien savoir pour te
payer ma tête
moi même je te raconterai après si tu
veux alors d'ailleurs moi c'est fini
ben moi j'aimerais bien que ça
recommence tu capable de garder à saclas
michel de toi tu penses bien tu as fait
des blagues j'avais pu en faire comme
tout le monde on peut j'aime mieux ça
d'ailleurs ces vieux cette histoire-là
ya plus d'un an
tu n'as rien de marqué à l'époque il ya
un an avec robert o par robert soulas
son grand âge c'est jean-louis que
jamais si tu veux savoir ce petit jean
louis voyez-vous sa sale tête elle est
aussi un pendant les examens à 10
partout des jeunes est souvent ensemble
au restaurant on avait même dit
d'arrêter
ils entrent à centrale n'a sa sortie en
se mariaient enfin je croyais je n'avais
même dit à moi papa comme ça faut
attirer pour voir il m'avait répondu à
ton âge tu es folle
ah non mais ça lui va bien maintenant
cela mais qu'est ce qu'il est devenu
jean louis son père a été nommé zinjibar
dans l'administration à il va laisser
tomber
vous commencez mikli v descartes mois
des lettres et puis un jour plus rien ça
se fait ça va mieux
donc là heureusement je serais mort et
tu pense encore à lui moi je m'habitue
sa mort depuis voiture garde m'intéresse
je trouve tous moches merci à présent je
peux épouse et n'importe qui procès ce
que je ferai d'ailleurs une fin pour
commencer et toi à moi c'est un autre
genre
de quoi rire figure toi que secret la
presse que je vais raconter tu penses
bien bas qu'est ce que tu penses de
thérèse vous mettez pas saclay toi aussi
l acam regarder ça y est c'est
formidable si j'osais c'est pour te dire
que papa après tout a peut-être ses
raisons tu as aimé tu devrait comprendre
une enfin charleville avait mon âge
c'était normal tandis que papa bas
mettons qu'il est anormal c'est régulier
tu acceptes toi qu il épouse une fille
de 20 ans tu admets bon faut bien c'est
lui qui commande
en ce qui me concerne je donnais toullec
cette fille ne sera pas la même pourquoi
ces gentils une petite merde comme ça on
a su être mais j'ai complètement fou
papa bah c'est même pour ça qu'il était
vrai et bien michel puisqu'il en est
ainsi je serais folle moi aussi et je
sais autant que lui je suis libre moore
et puisqu'il trouve normal déposer une
fille de 20 ans je vais moins aussi
d'offrir un spectacle jeu des pronos
j'ai donc eu de quoi il allait rentrer
dans le même air que lui et nous verrons
qui lâchera le premier je peux avoir un
enfant moi aussi oh bah moi aussi il n'y
a pas de raison
attends un peu que je trouve une proie
n'importe qui premières investit venu et
tu verras je m'étais planté o
ça va martine tu ne me répond pas aux
régimes est serti fâché mois flashy avec
un pareil j'ai tort au contraire
ouais
dis moi tu bouillant presse de galles
super bonjour michel
tu me paraît bien nerveux ce matin ma
petite martine je suis heureuse quand je
te vois c'est quand tu pars en voyage je
suis triste quand tu es malade je suis
un actuel j'attends dimanche pour te
voir
je n'y peux rien et toi non plus mais
qu'est ce qui se passe chez eux à bout
l'amour un an la demander en mariage
c'est moi qui demandait qui me plaira
mon choix est fait depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs un choix heureux un devine tu
ne t'es jamais marié toit
barret tu dois ça ne s'est pas pour une
écart non c'est ma foi je pense même
qu'ils n'aiment pas l'effort beaucoup de
3 pour choisir entre 100 on doit se
contenter d'être gagnant quand on n'est
pas seul à pouvoir être fidèle de mal
d'ailleurs j'ai quelquefois des regrets
mais dis moi tu as de jolies mains
n'avais jamais remarqué ça tu
intelligente et musiciens jeux d'argent
et la conversation parle bien tu
t'habilles avec vous mais tu n'as pas de
porte
mais elle a vu sortir enfin j'ai tout de
même 47 ans elle ment comment bof ça n'a
rien à voir à michel bon
non sérieusement tu veux j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi tu n'es tpas bal du
diable si je m'attendais appareils
questionnaire je suis une gagnante c'est
maintenant non j'ai pas dit ça ne sommes
pas exactement à 100 ans
mais qu'est ce que tu as ce matin
pour ma part de loin partenaires de ton
âge je me sens d'expérience et préoccupé
d'abord de sa petite personne à michel
bats c'est à dire qu'à moi les hommes de
50 ans ne font aucun effet mais je
reconnais qu'une femme encore joly sur
le tard il y en a peut-être une très
agréable maîtresse de qui on peut avoir
beaucoup à apprendre
surya le cardon on est ensemble la
preuve en est que les vrais jeunes
filles d'aujourd'hui n'ont d'autre
refuge que dans les bras qu'on sait
mieux leur ouvrir à ton âge j'en suis
sûr qu'à celui de michel tu peux encore
avoir des enfants
ben [ __ ] membres d'une secte et mémé
voiture tu es bien énigmatique se bat
non non non non non pas qu'ils patridge
attend qu'il est bientôt droit à petit
je dois alors quoi peux-tu ennakl qui
t'énerve à nankin
je suis très calme et très sincère que
tu crois ou non et saint michel que je
suis sincère trop trop mais jouer ton
père qu'est ce qu'ils fabriquent ce
matin ils travaillent de façon toute pas
de bile pour lui il se débrouille très
bien je me sens beaucoup d'ailleurs
qu'il a toujours dit oui et toi
l'attitude ce matin le confirme à
paroles visent aussi folle que lui obama
vienne à certaines mois et ils tuent a
pas eu peur de poids pour le temps ça va
mieux
tu es bien très bien très bien oui tu es
charmante martin mais il faut comprendre
avec un autre que moi tu risquerais
d'être imprudente
en fait je suis fait le genre de la
petite maîtresse de maison que tu à mes
yeux brillants mais on attend qu'elle
saura pas quand on fait la pop était
charmante et bien sûr mais puissante en
rend compte qu'ils oublient que tu as
tout de même 20 ans et mais que si moi
je ne sais plus je ne suis pas pour
autant et sensible mais je ne t'attends
pas comme ça veut dire michel empêchera
en fait
j'ai laissé seuls deux minutes non je
t'en prie michel je ne serai pas discret
j'ai compris qu'est ce qui la conduit un
dîner devine toujours pas j'espère bien
que non si je te pose franchement une
question tu répondras dépendent à créer
n'importe laquelle
vas tu aimerais me sortir de sortir mais
où ça pourquoi de ma vie que tu jamais
en restaurant seuls tous les deux en
tête à tête
non j'en serais martin alors pourquoi
mambé ne tue jamais un week-end n'a pas
envie mais toi non plus j'espère oui
pardon c'est à moi de faire des avances
pas plusieurs fois qu'à moi et elle est
complètement folle ce matin là tu ne vas
pas tranché à quel propos
depuis longtemps je rêvais de bavarder
sérieusement avec toi mais je n'osais
pas c'était normal je me disais
qu'est-ce que dire à mon père mais à
présent qu'il avait une fille de matin
j'ai pas pourquoi je me gêne réelle moi
c'est pareil mais non ce n'est pas
pareil tué sa fille je suis son ami je
ne suis pas ton père c'est pourquoi j'ai
une envie folle de t'embrasser fait mal
au moral
c'est flatteur pour moi mais c'est
excessif d'autant plus que ce n'est pas
vrai que ça ne peut pas pourquoi je n'ai
pas loin d'être heureuse
il a bien lui on peut tu peux m'en
branché sur le fond sur la joue bien sûr
comme une gentille petite fiole côté là
la seconde échouer tir de judo et sur la
bouche martin et ses troupes et la
mitaine
alors là martin je vais te parlait
carrément puisque ton comportement
biopic le piquant est une norme est il
plausible est il sensé est admissible
qu'une jeune fille de 20 ans face à cros
l'homme que je suis voilée réfléchis tu
as la tête solide déjà passé son bac
avec mention
je t'ai connu j'avais trois jours il a
dit tu as grandi depuis c'est vrai mais
tu es devenu presque une jeune femme
enfin comment pourrais je m'apprêtais à
ce jeu même s'il était sincère ce que je
me refuse à croire
il n'a pas l'âme en déduit donc pas de
bêtises à leur langue mais si par hasard
je te mets vraiment moi à l on s en
serait beaucoup plus ennuyé pour toi que
pour moi ah parce que de moi on dirait
il s'embête pas cadeau ou me de toi de
toi
vous vous rendez compte cette gamine
hall en voyant ma petite martin soyons
sérieux on est chez toi c'est dimanche
je reviens de la messe pour faire ou
alors pouvoir me rendre le système si
mon bonheur est un fait que cette fois
martine c'est assez mais qui n'est pas
malade mais aucune martin jaite en chef
il faut préparer le grand chose parce
que j'ai beau ne plus être dans la
course mais à la fin du même nom mais
martin et agit donc pas comme ça je t'en
prie michel michel arrive en face à bah
oui j'ai de bons soient là je t'en prie
messieurs longtemps de ce cadeau vous ne
vous attendiez pas celle là
et toi ma soeur c'est l'avenir qui tira
au jeu bonjour je vend mon cher cadeau
je ne sais pas si vous êtes gagnants
mais je constate que vous qu'on a placé
on ne m'entendait pas vraiment par des
placards u17 à la lettre car cela vous
trouvez gamme moins que vous ne le
pensez madame c'est à dire
demandez-lui hop j'ai rien à dire tu ne
m'as pas d'hier en cours que tu trouvais
madame très belle et que tu en rêvais
mais ce matin même quand il sait qu'elle
venait déjeuner tu n'as pas du cheval je
m'intéresse quelle belle journée
j'aime quand j'ai dit chouette c'est
vrai c'est d'aimer quand je viens ici
ils sont beaucoup à décider mon cher
cadeaux l'état de veuves étaient
incomplets françois ne vous fait pas de
bile pour lui il s'occupe avec une jeune
élève je parais exactement il a bien
raison
et ne me parlez surtout pas les couples
la sortie même éducation mais ma erreur
chaque cas est égoïste est rien
tandis qu'avec le décalage y en a des
vues qui cherchent à gatineau
c'est tellement mieux n'a rien l'autre
reçoit
oui parce qu'aujourd'hui la sont les
propos de printemps mais sont très
intéressants madame kespa michel aux
huîtres est intéressant c'est vrai quand
je pense que si j'avais 20 ans je me
ferai peut-être des leviers gare alors
qu'aujourd'hui
mieux aujourd'hui se serait volontiers
d'un verre comment les faits mais vous
êtes magnifique madame n'est ce pas
michel or merveilleuse ne met-il pas
vraiment depuis le premier jour où je
vous ai vu j'étais bouleversée mais tu
ne l'as jamais rien les séparaient à ben
je prenais sur moi
cent fois j'ai voulu le dire mais josep
à sa timide à ce point malgré des airs
de conquérant au il ya six mois que je
me dis tous les jours ce sera pour
demain
quel dommage
quel dommage subtil entendu vous avez
dit quel dommage
alors je peux oui peut il peut quoi je
peux
normal
c'était
mais martin mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette tenue est comme celle en voilà des
manières mais vous vous tolérez madame
de ce gamin enfin deux pareillement à
son aise avec vous sorti depuis un an à
peine de vos épreuves étaient moins
chers amis du petit singe de s'offrir
bon nombre enfin mes enfants dans ma
maison est ce possible
des toits cadeau tu veux te couvert de
ridicule avec une enfant qui pourrait
tout à fait enfin il faut en déporté
juif en ce moment mais vous à lomé où
allons-nous c'est vraiment la cohérence
et rennes enfin quoi et ici chez vous
alors à ce thème tout de même ma mère
n'a plus qu'à prendre un amant et pasqua
quoi
[Musique]
tout est clair dans l'esprit mais je
peux compter sur toi là contient vos
démarches
la musique tient on tiens j'aurais juré
on surfe la coulant je vous prends un
tous les deux ou séparément
sais tu t'arranges mon père tué m alors
tous les deux aussi bien moi si je
dérange je peux m'écarter du reste je
reste assez vous et 1 ou 3 martin
d'abord je t'adore martine tu le sais tu
es ma fille tu es mon bien le plus
précieux de tous ces deux mondes merci
pour le mal ce qui m'a toujours plu en
toi c'est ta franchise ton équilibre ta
santé physique et morale bref tu es bien
ou plutôt que les textes un frère non
inutile de souffler j'arrive série
qu'est ce que disait j'arrive série
j'arrive tout
d'intelligence ou en étage
tu es bien et moi j'ai répondu c'est un
frère j'ai toujours eu porté à martin
des trésors d'indulgence je sais que tu
mérites ma confiance tu là enfin ou
plutôt tu l'avais lorsqu'enfin pourquoi
cette folie subite mais je suis très
calme mais tu as 19 ans martin ne
l'oublient pas si tu veux tu oublies que
cadeaux et comme tous les vieux
célibataires ne peut qu'être sensible
aux hommages d'une jeune fille et tu ne
t'appartient pas de le provoquer ni des
veillées en lui je ne sais quel trouble
le pense est incompatible avec son
argent quand tu comprends j'espère si
oui on n'a pas rappelé la télé la petite
prière que je voulais a dressé comme un
père le doigt je pense que
l'avertissement est sans objet ils les
laissent pas comment ça je suis ok ça
veut dire ça pourquoi ça a plus besoin
je voudrais je ne plaisante pas je lai
qu'est ce que j'aime bien je lai non
mais oui ça vachement tendue vers hélène
pâquis lmk tout bas elle te le dis je
serais tu phone martin je le trouve
beaucoup de charme j'y peux rien
mais pillent et ouvrit cadeaux enfin me
des lunettes
puis son un vieillard demain à son âge
les hommes sont sous complet dégâts
réalisations auxquelles une vraie jeune
femme n'est pas indifférent ch
oui sans doute peut-être ça arrive même
pas à quoi bon à ma fille n'est en rien
entre eux vous j'espère pas encore donc
thomas pas encore mais gare à jamais
rien et il pourra rien y avoir un mais
je te dirai non médias qui testait dit
elle te dira mais le fait on parle
perroquet toi même si tu faisais rien
cadeaux je me demande je répète non à la
lgv
raisonnons martin qu'est ce que tu lui
trouve de bien un cadeau c'est
indéfinissable j'aime j'aime sa voix sa
conversation son charme son visage
enjoué sévère même ses traits à peu
marqué mais tellement viril et
l'attirant c'est pas de ma faute si je
suis heureuse car je le vois et même si
j'en rêve toutes les nuits je raconte
elle en rêve le rêve toutes les nuits
est le deal de cadeaux oui et toi y'a
pas moi
trois boucles non tu me demande ça va
bien vraiment de plaisanter parce qu'on
a un sujet aussi grave au alors qu'à toi
aussi michel j'ai précisément une
observation a présenté à moi à laquelle
je prierai de répondre sans détour je
prends prendre des gants avec toi bon
admettons que ta soeur soit au stade de
d'un épanouissement qui se cherche
voilà je me cherche on se cherche elle
s'achète d'où un certain flottement un
égarement momentanée mon dieu elle voit
cadeau à travers ses lunettes de romans
la mesure pas clairement tout ce qui la
sépare de lui les jeunes filles parfois
ondes et aux cadets se jette au cou du
premier venu
c'est un autre problème make-up 24 tu te
rends compte
bon et toi quoi moi à toi tu es qui
assiste déjà ton patron dans les
opérations qui devraient tous même te
donner à réfléchir sur la gravité de la
vie que tu m'expliques et les raisons de
ta conduite aussi inconvenante envers
thérèse et pourquoi tu n'as pas cessé
depuis ce matin hors de propos de le
rabaisser les manies de lui baiser les
mains mêmes ou dessert de lui serrer la
taille sans parler des acrobaties auquel
se livraient tes jambes sous la table
ronde à bâle ne nie pas les butins j'ai
même des bleus jean les plus gros enfin
quoi y'a pas assez d'infirmières à
l'hôpital on voit si tu crois qu'elles
sont à ma disposition
avec tous les patrons qui cherchent à
s'occuper eux les intéresse ils ont du
fric pour les sortir en tout cas je
t'invite ici dans ma maison est aussi la
tienne observer une attitude descente
vis-à-vis d'une femme à peine remise
d'un gros chagrin d'amour aux mêmes si
elle en est remise qui ne correspond en
rien à sa situation à ton âge à
l'indépendance et au calme que requiert
tes études à ton âge on travaille et on
tient on s'amuse il est indécrottable
qui ça mais tout a pas fan non mais tu
ne te rends par contre que thérèse n'a
pas attendu pour se consoler mais tu
oublies toutes les aventures qu'on lui
prête bien à tort ou à raison à raison
vraisemblablement ça devrais pas te
citer à la prudence
1 à moins qu'ils ne fassent plaisir de
te retrouver en 2e classe parmi le
bataillon le sésame 1
ça fait mais je ne dit pourtant que la
vérité tu vas tout même pas me faire
croire qu'une femme aussi averti
expérimentés j'allais dire aussi
entraîné ces mêmes aguerris à 43 ans
qu'elle a est bien celui que l'inde et
paraît capable de prendre au sérieux des
plaisanteries de carabin tu continues
arrive
à l'arrêt pour moi elle te plaît
beaucoup je suis ici que de l'avis plaît
beaucoup c'est normal c'est normal
elle ne dépend pas toujours de nous de
raisonner nos sentiments sais pas
pourquoi des fois on part en prise non
pas en crise mais des phrases qu'elle
consente à 20 mégas sûrement très l'émoi
des atomes crochus cas dès le premier
jour où je les ai vus j'ai été attiré
vers elle comme les d'huile vers les
moon le premier jour mais oui ya 11 ans
a tué sa première communion les
vachettes et précoce tu ne vas quand
même pas me dire qu'à dix ans puisque tu
en as 21 maintenant cet amour achats
déjà d'une femme mariée qui en avait
largement à croire à des peuples et un
mari est en pleine santé qui n'a pas
besoin de ce coup on va nous mais elle
pourrait être ta mère thérèse il ya eu
filière si je laime la filière n'a rien
à part la tragédie antique l'expliquer
ils sont énormes et insensé comment je
dis que vous êtes énorme et insensée à
passer ça j'avais bien compris que je ne
déroge pas non non pas du tout j'étais
capable de parler en eau dans mes
enfants de leurs études c'est très
important
voulez-vous avoir l'amabilité de faire
patienter nos affiliés dans le jardin
je la rejoins dans un instant au fait
comment la trouvez-vous son charmant
très intelligent gallen voilà le monde
est si jeune à vous mon cher ami une
petite rectification
je suis né en 1931 alors faites le
calcul mais ne l'aggravé pas merci
elle a dû abbas al aouiss à la caisse
qu'elle peut me plaire
m'enfin que tu oublies que quand elle
aura 60 ans oui et alors 60 ans qui en
aura 40 appels oui mais ça ressemble à
quoi peut-être calcul bon non non non
écouter écoutez moi bien mais enfin bon
j'admets eu le double feu lit vous
conduisent parfois à des actes
inconsidérés
que vous soyez naïvement tenté par le
côté romanesque d'une aventure je
comprends tout ça vous dit tout ce que
je fais mais qu'à trouver tes rêves vous
arrivez au monde et toi et moi mais moi
à quel point ce mois je suis libre je
lâche de discerner de réfléchir de peser
mal je connais la vie moi je sais où je
n'ai je peut l'aborder
j'ai mes raisons moi je suis sincère et
moi bon alors martin est fini les
politesses père et toi et je te dirai
quand j'aurai fait le voyage à parce que
tu t'apprêtes à vient de voyage vous
voir d'abord c'est le paysage qui décide
ainsi vous vous me voyez inquiète pas
trop seul et affolé par en peptides et
ça vous est égal et toi tu deviennes
bien c'est pareil mon p'tit père mais
mais enfin mais moi non je réponde à des
plis jeu puisque c'est une simple
question qu'est ce qu'elle vous a fait
vous aviez pas pourquoi on revoir cette
jeune fille qui a tout pour elle la
distinction la loyauté la beauté l'éclat
le bon sens l'équilibré charme j'en
passe malheureusement et pourquoi
n'auraient cependant être heureux autre
bon bon bon bon ça va on se bat là tout
ce qu'il vous plaît de déménager là que
la folie règne
nous ferons à nous tous une famille
digne de l'antique toi 21 ta femme 42
réals 19 et son mari cinq ans et maman
maman 20 et maman va un moment mais
après pour peu qu'on ait des enfants le
grand oncle aura de massy mois 150 2 et
notre mère à 20 ans la grand mère et
après une autre mère sera grand mère
d'un pour les petits fils dans mon père
pour être son grand-père
si vous saviez le tracteur qui me donne
c'est le leur j'ai du mal à le croire et
je suis sûr qu'il vous adore merci
merci mes enfants merci de me dire merci
même s'il ya un peu d'ironie dans votre
molitès c'est tout à fait naturel et
j'aurais mauvaise grâce à me il faut les
laisser leur donner le temps de me
connaître moi même je ne peux encore que
les deviner je ne vous suis pas
sympathique c'est cela aussi maman
véritable enfer mais qui les a élevés
par immense bon ben on va papa
c'est vrai ils sont jeunes ils ont droit
à toutes les indulgences
ils ont le devoir de me b iront pas trop
demander surtout pas te demander à la
fois ils ne peuvent pas comprendre et
moi-même à l'orage s'est on est
peut-être un sourire un peu jaloux
vous entendez ce noble et langage vous
autres papas vous appréciez au moins
c'est un délicatesse cette intelligence
et indulgent cette classe qui éclatent
dans le mot est dans la nation c'est pas
admirable vous êtes merveilleux c'est
pas vrai aussi alors dit que si c'est
vrai ça y est on est on laissait les
france soir rien de tout ça les graves
ce qui apporte c'est votre travail
mais quand je sois moi digne de lui et
que la part l'autre ne soyons heureux
vous savez combien je le suis les lignes
venez à tout à l'heure mais enfants
qu'elles le sont aniane et d'ingénieurs
pas la demoiselle pas une chanteuse qui
parle elle connaît la musique
pourquoi c'est ce que si elle est
chanteuse bon je crois qu'on ferait
mieux de laisser tomber tu sais jamais
celle ci ne sera pas ma mère je jure
sont à terre battue manor merci bien
michel moi je vous attends on ne fait
par les cas noté parce que vous auriez
déjà changé d'avis qu'il faudrait que ce
soit moi qui fasse les avants oh tu es
gentiment tu me laisses deux minutes
s'il te plaît michel je dois vous parler
sérieusement surtout après l'incident de
ce matin et les réflexions de votre père
dont tout surplus je balance dit ma
michel où en êtes-vous de votre médecine
ya longtemps qu'on savait qu'avancer
trois ans je termine ma première année
mais j'ai remarqué que vous défendiez
très bien au tennis je me défends sans
plus alors ne soyez pas modeste vous
êtes très fort j'ai remarqué votre
détente
je suis en deuxième série eh ben vous
méritez la première mais ce match est
comme un dieu j'ai beaucoup d'alluré sur
le court vous trouvez je m'y connais en
athlète
merci ah bon vous avez l'air de ta
timide et avec michel vous étiez ciardi
pendant le déjeuner quoi c'est votre
père or lui demande pourquoi ce frein
n'allez pas croire madame ya pas de
frein bien au contraire
oui maintenant michel moi j'aimerai
savoir par son père à 11h55 vous vous
jeter sur moi comme un tigre reprennent
le dévorer j'aurais dû me fâcher si j'en
avais eu envie et puis enfin tout
pendant tout le déjeuner là vous n'avez
pas cessé de me coincer la cheville
contre le pied de la table
ça veut dire quoi cette gymnastique dont
elle est sincère
vous vous en doutez bien un peu alors je
pose la question seriez-vous instable au
pas du tout c'est même beaucoup plus
sérieux que je ne le croyais au départ
c'est vrai je sens même que sam gagne
mais qu'est-ce qui vous gagne vous vous
en doutez bien du tout c'est difficile à
expliquer j'ai compris série mercy
vous êtes très jeune vous n'avez pas
encore l'habitude mais quoi nous sommes
seuls alors confié vous vous êtes
tellement belle que je ne peux que vous
admirez et vous désirez alors écoutez
moi bande michel c'est très grave ce que
vous me dites là d'abord à ne rien vous
cacher moi j'adore les jeunes gens alors
à plus forte raison quand ils sont cinq
sportifs et vigoureux or vous n'avez
rien à leur envier
je vous ai fait en maillot de bain ou
est ce qu'on m'a dit je n'arrive pas à
croire ma chance
c'est merveilleux n'est ce pas est ce
qu'on fait
dis moi mon petit michel tu aime la
musique la musique oui j'adore la
musique
alors écoute moi si tu promets d'être
sage ce soir je t'invite à la maison je
jouerai du mozart et puis ensuite
ensuite nous pourrons tous les deux
gentiment au champagne et après en tous
les cas
dis moi une chose franchement mon petit
michel cavret main sentiments pour moi
j'ai besoin de savoir
moi aussi mais tu sais tu embrasses bord
bien où est le mérite une bouche pareil
dis donc tu n'iras pas de monter au
moins s'annonce tendu je suis veuve
après tout on ne sait trop peu rugueux
garder pour moi un aussi beau secret on
va la musique mais son père un petit
appel à bord
oui je voudrais faire un petit a fait
parce que je t'aime beaucoup et puis au
fond je suis terriblement sentimentale
tu sais alors je sais j'en ai pas l'air
aussi et quand j'aime quelqu'un tu sais
comment ça se traduit chez moi par
l'intérêt très grand que je porte à la
personne aimée par le besoin de lui être
agréable d'être fier de lui d' d'en
faire un as un crack un champion et tu
sais ce qui me ferait vraiment plaisir
mon petit michel c'est que tu deviens un
jour un grand médecin que tu passes
l'internât d'abord et que les concours
les hôpitaux
oui je voudrais provoqué en toile le
bout soudaine a réussi de la première
place pouvoir me dire voilà ce que j'ai
fait lui lui c'est moi je les bacs
france travailleront au train de nous
allons ça ira tout seul et puis un jour
bien sûr rien seulement tu vois ce jour
là si j'ai la consolation de me dire que
je n'ai pas été étranger intérêt ici tu
es bien m'en contenterai on faire la
musique
une dernière petite prière ne laissons
rien paraître ou du petit événement tu
veux nous nous éclipseront séparément au
contraire de nom à ton père l'impression
que nous sommes fâchés
il faut savoir mentir quand on essaie on
épluche sig est tranquille tu ne seras
pas en peine de trouver un bon prétexte
pour me rejoigne je ferai tout ce que
vous voudrez madame c'est gentil
alors écoute moi bien je t'attendrai
derrière ma peau et je te ferai la
surprise oui enfin ça y est ça
recommence mais pas la folle il est très
bientôt faire mal à tout à l'heure au
hall musique ça marche très bien
mais pas trop bien j'espère sur pattes
les sans abri gâter ses rêves et dames
la température est en hausse
à l'autre c'est michel petit nous
laisser quelques instants s'il te plait
je ne serai pas indiscret je vous laisse
les amoureux ce que j'ai à te dire
martinez est très délicat
je déconne une petite fille de tes
charmes en tulle est resté naturellement
mais tu as pris avec l'âge de
l'importance à 20 ans les montants sont
et un sens un poids si tu préfères qui
ne peuvent manquer laisse indifférent
celui qui les ai cru je suis très
perplexe martin un peu nerveux je
l'avouer à certains égards angoissé
vraiment ce qui me surprend c'est ce qui
me trouve
c'est la raison pour laquelle qui me
prêtent depuis ce matin une attention à
laquelle tu il m'avait guère habitué je
ne me fais aucune illusion on remarque
tu peux être trop modeste
je vais tout dire martin ce jeu que de
pratiquer est extrêmement dangereux pour
toi et pour moi aussi si tu apprécies
depuis longtemps et admire avec un autre
que moi tu prenais le grand risque avec
l autre que toi d'abord un homme tu t'en
doutes bien et n'est jamais insensible à
l'intérêt que lui porte une femme est
large et de tous les détails
celui que l'on oublie le plus facilement
tu me suis
ce que je te dis là n'a d'autre objet
que de les mettre en garde contre des
imprudences dont les suites pourraient
jeudi pourraient être graves parce que
ne le sont pas parce que je me repose de
toute la force de ma région parce que
j'en ai pouvoir que décidément femme
jusqu'au bout des ongles
tu me fais peur martin si bien
tranquille supposant seul instant qu
encourager par des propos je me laisse
prendre au jeu
ce serait un malheur je te trouve belle
mais tu te révèle tout à coup à moi
c'est le jour d'une jeune fille beaucoup
plus avertis que je l'imaginais tarbes
le sait la première conversation
sérieuse que nous avons ne croyez pas
que je serai flatté comblé de joie les
plus grandes si je pouvais sortir avec
toi
entré au restaurant
mardi au plaisir d'enregistrer 2 d
étonnement des émotions des découvertes
de sortir de gâter le temps des rangs
voyage guettait a fêté son anniversaire
mieux quand parent en amis en confident
avec espoir mais au fond tu t'ennuies
ici et peut-être serait dur a dit de
partir en croisière de découvrir le
monde même avec moi mais pourquoi même
avec toi un dernier aveu martin sincère
je te prie de le croire et que tu me
pardonneras je découvre aujourd'hui un
sentiment nouveau que j'ai un certain
mérite à vouloir ignorer
tu comprends à présent un sentiment un
vrai tu penses vraiment ce que tu dis là
je veux que tu saches adorable martin
que ce sentiment là est très beau très
pur très neuf ne le crois moi tu
apprécieras le mérite que je peux avoir
à être raisonnable en cet instant mais
pourquoi vouloir toujours être
raisonnable
pourquoi toujours des arguments contre
le bundle est démolie paille ne sont pas
tellement solide mes arguments
voilà pourquoi en produire 100 ans pour
être sûr qu'ils existent vraiment sinon
n'est pas bien certains mais certains de
quoi d'être incapable de thé mais de ne
pas mériter une bonne fois dans ma vie
la confiance de lettres qui a le bonheur
de me plaît vois-tu et martin je t'aime
mieux peut-être que je ne saurais le
faire si j'avais ton âge ce que tu peux
me barbe et avec l'âge ça veut dire quoi
attention attention école ralentir
danger
mais pour toi 2 pour toi aussi moi j'y
prête à courir le risque mais parce que
tu ne mesurent mal c'est naturel mais
s'il me plaît ce risque avant de le
prendre le risque paie toujours
si je suis franche avec toi tu m'en
voudra pas un instant sais tu que c'est
très grave ce qui m'arrive tout d'un
coup mais je ne fais que le répéter au
début c'était une blague
pas une minute je ne pensais à t'aimer
genre et riz est maintenant à tanger
je vais tâcher de te dire mais tu
viendras pour toi le secret mais ces
merveilleuses que tu dis là baptiste
martin aux secrets entre nous comme j'ai
appris que mon père allait serait mariée
j'ai voulu barrer la route à son projet
et si je t'ai sauté au cou ce matin
c'était pour me mettre en travers ou lui
montrer combien elle était ridicule et
l'obligé à renoncer alors tu tombé pile
je t'ai choisi michel lui a fait croire
à thérèse mais pour nous amuser tu
comprends mais pour en revenir à notre
histoire car à présent on a une histoire
nous de nous au début sans suite ne sais
pas car au fond je ne te connaissais pas
c'est pour têtu et de la famille et puis
voilà que je suis prise à mon piège tout
vrai je te découvre tu ouvrais j'entends
ta voix et et je lis ton visage pour la
première fois maintenant je ne jure donc
pas je jure et même je ne comprends pas
c'est comme un sens que tu donnais ma
vie là tu exagère mais je vis ce que je
pensais plutôt ce que je sens car depuis
un moment je ne pense qu'à te voir qu'à
écouter
je ne sais même plus si tu es beau si tu
es jeune si je suis raisonnable si toi
tu n'es pas trek tm bouleverse martin
c'est extraordinaire tout ça si demain
j'aurai un regret puisqu'il hier je
n'avais même pas une pensée pour toi
alors demain aujourd'hui je suis attirée
c'est tout martin martins
voilà une chose que tu n'aurais jamais
dû faire
3 commence
mais qui la nomme monde qui pourrait me
reprocher je t'apporte une distraction
pas derrière moi voyage faudrait
connaître la terre entière
c'est petit et behra bâtiment même battu
à florange mois prochain l'affluence est
plus à venise est partout il te paierai
d'aller si ça pouvait ni pourquoi c'est
à peu près ça pue on verra à martil on
verra il faut le temps ont bien sûr les
billets les passeports les devine la
réflexion aussi on met ça beaucoup moins
d'importance
bien sûr titre reprend déjà non non non
je tiens à te laisser ta chance alors on
met deux mois comme tu dis ça comme elle
à 10 il y en a tant d'atouts gagne et on
va au cinéma ce soir au cinéma ce soir
avec ton père collection mohlala non non
non il faut quitter tout de rien rassure
toi j'aime entrer une histoire on se
retrouve dans paris mais si je comprends
bien tu me proposes en rendez vous ce
soir c'est toi qui décide comment dirais
je ne sais pas petit à petit le colisée
à la terrasse est puis sera fait
première c'est fou ce qui m'arrive là
mais bon dieu que c'est bon pardon voilà
papa à moi je peux pas te voilà j'espère
que tu n'es plus franche et j'étais
justement en train de raisonner martyrs
toi elle a compris tout est au mieux un
bonhomme comme je te comprend au regard
des magazines et des fous tu vois comme
moi à travers comme je dis à ta place et
par là la musique me sortir est partout
en cherchant sa chance à 6,10 savez si
tu savais combien ton bonheur ma région
ne parlons plus de l'incidence est
oublié j'ai un patin chers petits pape
comme et l'addition
comme l a dit ça gentiment évoqué le
sexe en appellerait de jovenna donne une
prime bruit et tout ça grâce à vous
mademoiselle car l'amour quand ça vous
arrive au pas rapidement qu'avec une
fusée pour la lune c'est pas parce qu'on
ne sait pas jouer et vous chère madame
cher ami du maroc il fait beau que
j'écoute de la musique et que je joue
mozart comme je vous comprends
et tu sais à quel point je te fais
confiance en soi j'hésitais à faire la
faire de l'ombre au tarot et bien tant
pis je signe on verra bientôt puisque
vous êtes tous charmant et que je vais
travailler avec les diplômes à une heure
comme tous les jours et ensuite je vous
emmène tous dîner d'accord je suis
désolé je ne sais plus je joue à savoir
ce soir c'est pas possible parce que
j'ai je vais au concert
puis il faut d'ailleurs partie de mon
côté impossible françois j'ai justement
rendez vous avec des amis de 2,2 zurich
un possible de dîner avec toi tu n'as
qu'à elle et des commandes et des
commandes et du suisse mais tu n'y
penses pas susceptible comme le sont ces
gens là on roule alors je me contenterai
d'amener les enfants à bambi vais moi
faut que je revois mon anatomie
j'ai mon examen 27 tourner anatomy à
dimanche balade tiens si tu voyais le
bouquin qu'est-ce qu'il faut se mettre
dans le crâne et moi justement qu'elle
aime préparer pour aller dîner avec
jacqueline mais tu sais bien chakim
diminue le trottoir alors tant pis nous
devons tous ensemble une autre
je suis enchanté de la journée vous
aimez bazin qui est l'idée de me
demander si j'ai most
encore merci pour ce bon déjeuner
françois et bravo pour tes chansons en
quel dommage il aurait fait si bon dîner
ici ce soir sur la terrasse et la
terrasse 7
mon petit papa ben alors on peut partir
du bas s'est efforcé de les inviter mais
en réalité tarde d'être au sol avec toi
et moi qui avais peur de ferries suffit
d'une étrangère était tranquille alors
tu crois vraiment que la sphère de nom
de basse faire l'ombre et après nous y
aura beau me dire j'ai de la chance
non pas ce mot il est pour moi à vous
monsieur excusé mensonge elle mais la
grille du parc était ouverte et j'ai pu
venir jusqu'ici vont enquêter un
renseignement fait le travail à monsieur
je vous remercie de votre accueil vous
êtes la courtoisie même mais n'êtes vous
pas françois le grand je suis me sera
monsieur vous avez composé une valse à
laquelle je prédis le tour du monde
soyez prophète mes hommages madame ou
mademoiselle la demoiselle les charmants
et je comprends qu'on le sait déjà
avis c'est une petite réminiscences
cédant à nouveau troisième acte amano on
va faire un mollet ces lieux je vois là
bas une autre m'annoncer main lourde
mais oui maintenant maintenant oui venez
vous désirez voilà l'objet de la visite
je vous remercie et vous mettez un élève
vous êtes bien les vagues voilà voilà
les faits en 1938
j'ai joué pour la dernière fois carmen à
l'opéra de monte carlo
carmen parle moi de vous ma mère
il n'est pas question de départ
l'honneur de la connais tu t'amènes
j'étais don josé
et quel don josé à vous pouvez m'arrêter
j'ai tué le macadam est tombé à mes
débuts ça va s'arranger
voire de gloire soir d'adieu à que le
merveilleux signée jean suis sûr mais en
quoi puis-je vous éclairer vesoul ce
soir là j'aurais dû mourir mourir effet
votre 3 am les angoisses comme à tours
et par celle du désespoir nous mourir
des suites et est fort dommage vous avez
l'air encore très jeune à l'époque
vraiment un travail très jeune n'ont pas
plu à c est beaucoup trop plus assez
pour garder mon emploi et est beaucoup
trop pour le quitter sans regrets mais
nous en sommes tous faire ce pas la vie
est ainsi faite à une chasse de nos
métiers de nos emplois de nos amours
elle nous laisse parfois un assez
longtemps pour en savourer leur gré tout
ceci soit dit sans amertume
parce que je n'en ai jamais eu l up et
suis bavard
il les tient nous vous disions est ce
pas là encore 1932 à non 38 à 38 38 à
l'opéra de monte carlo où vous étiez
dans josé dont je connais tu le pays où
fleurit l'arrangé ça c'est mignon mignon
adomos un commandeur mignon c'est mignon
à celui c'est très mignon mais qu'est ce
qu'on voulait que ça fasse mais vous
souhaitez vous nombreux de préférer
c'était dangereux je ne sais pas le côté
militaire de la chaude à battle là qui
se la raconte d'alcala vous transat à
voile à ragon d'alcala ichat et fidèle
je dresse m'a pas l'air le coeur de ma
belle
la chaîne
je ne voulais pas mourir son te revoir
au brésil où je m'étais mariée sans
grand bonheur pas un jour depuis plus de
trente ans ne s'est écoulée sans que le
besoin ne fasse sentir de te retrouver
oussou alors j'ai pris l'avion trente
ans de liste d'accords vous avez fait
vite les habitants mines et tu n'as pas
chose au monde mais non mais non on a
gardé son éclat et enfin sa fraîcheur
préféré peut-être que nous vous
laissions seul et mon bonheur est le
même à te regarder lié à prendre ta main
oh que c'est thomas et froid laissez-moi
la réchauffe il le fait dans la bohème
premier rasta et mon désir et mes
projets vous avez vous demandé ma mère
un mariage ce qu'est ce que j'ai pu
manquer mais qu'est-ce que j'ai dû rater
on ne gardera pas près de moi mais tu
sais qu'ils auraient pu et on perd mêmes
jeunes demande
il n'est pas en niant ne les dates ne
concordent pas c'est dommage
l'adorable bambin que j'aurai la et
l'adorable petite fille si je ne faisais
tu sais que tu sais qu on te dire [ __ ]
à taiwan nous sa voix qui me rendait
plus amoureux que tous les amoureux du
répertoire et est ce que tu te souviens
de notre petite chanson celle que tu
aimais tant à ce qu'on sait mais avec
moi c'est mais ce qu'on sait mais tous
les deux du mois de janvier jusqu'à la
fin des ordres lui ne saura pas ce que
je n'avais est revenu tout près du ciel
dans notre touche en or c'est moi qu'on
sera tous les emplacements l'amour
pendant la tournée presse et nous vivons
[Musique]
pedone jeunes
et sow
frivole et retourne à l'école est la
pose de vitraux dans l'indonésie la
douceur de ses plus éminents
nos aînés se consolent les anime qui
sommes nous pour que les jours sur le
calendrier
rien n'a changé
de tous les cas rançonnaient seront les
anime contents ils disent ici dans notre
même tout bas il te voilà votre femme ne
cherchons pas à
[Applaudissements]
obama
joie à toi
ah ah
ap
[Musique]
allô allô oui ne quittez pas un c'est
pour toi michel allô bonjour tu es tu y
vois tu que je te répond sèchement je te
demande tout au plus à savoir ce que tu
fabriques et hier soir j'en ai le droit
je pense j'appelais dix fois entre mons
et réunir du matin ah non je regrette
car il n'était pas chez toi non
terrestre il n'était pas chez toi
et pourtant tu m'avais promis de ne pas
bouger comment t'as pas de comptes à me
rendre mes cité reste on a non teracent
pas dit était pas si toi mal aux halles
ou thérèse ne mettra bientôt fini
d'accaparer de téléphone poste ont pris
la vie est déjà pas si facile comme ça
hein mais toi qu'est ce que tu attends
vraiment bien familier à l'eau 966 83,11
crs 1 qui est réparé un mariage dont je
reviens ici monsieur michel we prier
madame de venir à l'appareil
comment elle pas la balle vient de
m'appeler oui bendit à madame que je
l'attends madame est pas là tu te rends
compte je te dire que quand je me rends
gloire à tanger quelqu'un a appelé avant
11h30 n'en reste plus rien de fixe à
bord rémy jamais de cadeau je viens
fontainebleau tous les deux allô allô
quoi madame fait sa toilette
j'attendrai qu'elle soit sortie du bain
même qu'elles soient sèches madame o les
femmes 1re et du chat manque cruel tour
à tour passionnés tyrannique en faut les
connaître
qu'est ce que tu en penses pour le
moment rien alors je l'appelle et hier
ne la mettez pas chez lg en fait la
remarque
madame se fâche il faudrait pas inverser
les rôles où allons nous alors il est
bientôt sèche madame vaches
attendrissant qui lui plaira par mois ap
patience mon père j'en ai bien moi ou à
propos des japonais a conduit au mois de
mai il est même question d'une machine
pour moi s'il te plaît l'état français
tu vois tu t'es tu devines je suis pas
encore un peu offert des cadeaux par
plusieurs hommes à la fois je serai vite
riche et tu n'acceptes pas j'ai vu
quelqu'un faisait 1 40
ma fille dire ça alors elle va sortir de
son bain tu as thérèse thérèse ce genre
de réflexion pour un père victoire
tu vas tu affiches et dans les lieux
publics avec un homme qui te promets une
voiture parts de son marché
un ami ton père temps par un toit une
veuve tout ça vous paraît logique et
spectable vous êtes satisfait mais c'est
beaucoup plus avec une porte tu
t'expliques il dit de ma complète des
tableaux à léo c'est toi chérie
berne alice mois tard mais il apporte
pourquoi tu fâché on réfléchit bien
c'est par votre système
mais je t'en supplie tu leur gré docteur
comment intéresser davantage sur son
dynamisme il dépasse quoi rien j'avais
déjà été et jamais tu sais bien mais tu
as non pli c'est vrai ça va durer
longtemps ce jargon à des 100 d'accord
on n'en parle plus je prends la voiture
de papa puisque la tienne est en panne
oui et puis on va casser la croûte à
villette se gênent plus on savait trajet
ce cas là bas j'en ai moi jusque là les
mois des records à tout à l'heure à
l'eau et bill martin martin oui oui oui
oui ni non
la main tendue à fontainebleau tu mets
serait faux nom c'est promis c'est parce
que je passe tu pas à leur faim quand tu
m'attends dans la grille
tu connais pas oui enfin une personne
[Musique]
non
les
il a l'air furieux
tu parlais à personne j'ai bien coiffé
pas trop de poule je fais pas pécore rod
est un bijou masseur vous dis moi tu as
une jolie croix et bella puis elle se
voit bien c'est une fois oui pour mon
anniversaire en plein qui m'a regardé
point son bail paraît et puis je te
parle pas du mois d'août on pensera aux
capteurs dans son domaine de laon
rayonnera disent heureux mais toi ma
place d'abord je sais où aller
ça me change un peu des petites
histoires de samedi en plus de ça tu
sais chez crg montcoy dans le pavillon
et puis tu sais sans vouloir
spécialement vente et on peut toujours
sortir avec thérèse ça se remarque c'est
comment elle m'appelle donc ans garçons
où mon grand toulouse
hu à sa douce sa merveilleuse on est
déjà tombé je crois je l'espère michel
les lois sur louis xi pas fait attention
quand même bien sûr moi tu comprends
j'ai la pâte moi c'est autre chose
je sais michel mars que je tendis la
scène en question de match mal placé
pour moi par lui mais enfin tu es ma
soeur c'est tout merci aux c'est naturel
dans ces eaux là pas pardon maintenant
vous m'accorderez tout à l'heure un
moment d'entretien maintenant elle est
venue à vous habiller et tu te crois où
pend hauteur de mes jours à 5 heures du
matin c'est encore au boulot comme ça
mon anatomie et après la terne à mon
petit peu en attendant la sinn et moi il
est question bien sa vision esthétique
[ __ ] j'aurais mon affaire un mois dans
les beaux quartiers je t'explique le
mécanisme je suis un peu et dont martin
mon temps on disait pardon enfin c'est
pas mal
osman ce qui m'arrive et extraordinaire
se doit un navet mais pointent encore
toi depuis cette visite armand je fais
tomber pour détendre je retrouve mes
impressions de 20 ans quand j'allais à
mes premiers rendez vous c'est comme un
premier mouvement
ça fait comme fort à 6 heures je prenais
ma douche moi qui traînent le matin en
dix minutes j'étais prête
on pourra rien je prenais le réveiller
j'étais énervé j'étais agacé alors pour
me calmer j'ai été faire ma gymnastique
tonnes
tu fais du yoga un jour je reçois dans
man of la visite d'un chef plonge
n'était cran les efforts un type un peu
particulier c'est vrai mais original en
dia avec une couleur pareil inn suites
ville en ville me prendre et de
compliments de fleurs de cadeaux de
bijoux je m'emballe et je décide de
l'épouser
j'étais comme ça c'est que je voulais
que vous êtes un bon mois eh ben il a
suffi qu'on dise mais voyons le logement
fha tu n'y penses pas
regarde le le voyons mais mettons
peaux-rouges la allons mais il est il
est plein de plumes
mais on peut vous êtes hu
on était pas aperçu cette baisse voire
encore
les autres voyaient les flux moi j ai
bien les enfants sont est comme moi
n'ont enfin thérèse n'est pas plein de
plus mme diallo n'a rien à voir c'est
frais c'est frais et brise ses prêts aux
tiens toi 18 ans tu voulait épouser
l'appelle madame voisins en avait 40
tous voulaient laver mais sont martelés
et après les textiles et les bains il a
suffi que je te dise les godillots en
soi qui ne pense pas regard de cette
dame et la clape hard
elle se rappelle c'est vrai je me
souviens elle piquait jamie a failli te
parle de sa vie mais tu été guérie mais
bien sûr et bavent des histoires mais
vous aussi rien avant désistement
malheur c'est que je ne sais pas mais ça
m'étonnerait un musicien artiste comme
toi tu penses à ce que je te dis mon
jour en salles a pas de cause évidente
et il avait des plaies
m
zammit cinq minutes cinq minutes dans 5
minutes vous serez libre mais voilà j'ai
longuement réfléchi à vos deux aventures
je me garderais bien d'en faire le
procès à vous avez droit comme tout le
monde à la joie de vivre ce droit je le
revendique il vous le revendiquez
tout ça est normal logique humains faut
être indulgent
j'ai toujours été je le suis je le seul
ah bon alors on peut partir qui n'a pas
à 20 ans adorent et une femme de
quarante moi même c'est vrai à cet âge
là les femmes sont belles la merde si
passionné instruite aux morts j'ai mordu
tu mords vous bien faire ses classes à
donc de ce côté-là papables art et chic
quant à toi martine je ne m'étonne qu'à
moitié et que tu ouvres naïvement
taiseux les yeux à la vie et que tu sois
sensible aux prévenance qu'on a pour toi
on en a deux
on en a beaucoup bon je l'admets ça
flatte pas je l'admets je ne verrais
aucun inconvénient sinon à encourager du
moins à tolérer son inclination un peu
surprenante il faut bien venir de m mené
au bonheur je me verrai je ne verrais et
ses célèbres
avec l armée nationale
connaissez votre grand-mère salle à
prendre tous les jours à la même heure
bon mais cheikh faty voilà qui voyait
blanc ce qui est rouge chère michèle
chère martine
c'est un supplice pour apercevoir
contrecarrer vos projets maintenant
donne surtout par la peine et ben baba
quand j'aurais parlé comme oran attendu
que vous déciderez martin il ne faut pas
aller déjeuner à fontainebleau ni toi
michel habib et pourquoi
à cause de la barde pour petits qui
voyait blanc ce qui est rouge et c'est
pato a marqué que j'aime adressé en
premier
tu me promet d'être courageuse cadeau
cadeaux que j'aime beaucoup je connais
depuis toujours ne mérite pas ta
confiance martin vraiment ma
connaissance il a deux maîtresses ont vu
l'une à neuilly et l'autre à vaugirard
la première une comtesse polonaise
terriblement jalouse
au point qu'elle l'a toujours empêché
d'épouser la seconde avec laquelle il a
eu deux enfants
c'est d'ailleurs une femme de dix ans
son aîné mais ils n'aiment vraiment
sérieusement que les femmes qui sont
plus âgés que lui et il est des jeunes
hommes déchets la polonaise anna manche
et de chez berthe dans la polonaise
s'appelle vanilla elle a un jour vanille
à la su j'ai été terrible
la venue de fée verte se sont battus en
pleine rue à deux points du trocadéro de
rue pétrarque est alors un cadeau à
l'époque a du sang sur il est paraît il
a pris un avion pour athènes avec sa
secrétaire lucette petit de 21
d'ailleurs adore appelé mais c'est elle
c'est peut-être qu'il l'a laissé tomber
un an après pour épouser un général turc
qu'elle avait rencontré sur place
c'est en assistant à pas vous mais tu
peux le dire
croyant tout connaître de la vidéo mais
quand je pense que depuis un mois il me
jour son amour
c'est un homme mais si tu savais ce
qu'il a pu me raconter de belles phrases
que vous et moi que chez alpha value
pour le croire j'ai grandi de ce tournoi
j'ai donc tout ce monde aura ce poids là
elle avait été si nous sommes en
principe animés de bonnes intentions
inconscients du mal qu'on peut faire
sincère à notre mode égoïste avant tout
et et cadeaux que j'aime beaucoup ce
n'est ni meilleure ni pire que les
autres je t'en prie pas surtout pas le
défendre
mais quand je pense on est si tu savais
mais ça n'est pas croyable mais ça l'est
mais ça n'est pas possible
mais quand il encore dit il à quelques
mois des larmes dans les yeux
conjonctivite
et puisqu'il faut tout dire j'en aurai
fini
bon je te signale que chaque jour il
prend l'apéritif place ferrer avec la
question du cinéma voisin ans
non je m'attable aurait pas cadeau
davantage c'est un ami on laisse michel
laisse ça lui fait du bien marquer
d'être une grande fille intelligente et
ford je suis sûre elle a compté à part
parce qu'il valait pas mieux que tous
soient avertis moi qui l'écoutaient
qu'il admirait comme il dad
quel [ __ ]
et maintenant attendons
oh bah si c'est un paquet du même source
après sports annonces etc
ça n'a rien à voir ah c'est encore plus
grave
oh
beaucoup plus grave autant autant
l'histoire de cadeaux est en quelque
sorte simple banal courant autant celle
de thérèse est alors vraiment cela
inquiétant au point que j'hésite est la
raconter bon bah tu peux y aller j'ai
fini de grandir sa vitrine michel que
thérèse avait déjà épousé enterré trois
mâts tels rsa enterré croit marie
thérèse en tête bien faite et la paix sa
fortune sur des aventures au point dès
qu'ils les plus ténébreux romands ne
sont que deux parmi lesquels lesquels et
bien débat gardien antoine faveur
d'antoine mais disparu au cours d'une
croisière khlouf un mois après qu'il
avait faite légataire d'une très grosse
affaire de caoutchouc synthétique à
levallois vous savez c'est ben non je
savais parler dans ces valeurs là et non
je trouvais pas de saveur et ghazi ghazi
ben coisy baisse notable du caire
rencontré par hasard chez prunier un
soir de réveillon un mois après l'épousé
en grande pompe à la madeleine un
musulman
voilà ma très jeune j'étais
la ola quel bel homme s'était rasé le
regard de feu taillée comme hercule jeu
faut encore se sont fais là fini trois
mois après ghazi était méconnaissable
c'est le bouquet mais qu'est ce qui lui
est arrivé a rasé amaigri voûté ghazi
était une loque qu'il fallait monter en
voiture
voilà ce qu'ils étaient devenus eurasie
malgré les gymnases manufacture de tabac
dont il était propriétaire on parle de
levallois elle va devoir lui aussi et
bien sûr aux portes de la rien tout ça
comment tout ça s'est il passé
[Musique]
j'ai horreur de la calomnie mais là
encore elle hérite à un patou non ils
avaient des enfants de cinq femmes
alors elle dut faire un procès par la
succession en son temps à vraiment
déchaîné la famille tu parles
comment ça aboutit je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas ghazi lui et il était mort
thème à la télé mais chers petits
l'histoire dramatique des deux marie
thérèse et le troisième le troisième
était prévu il y en avait pas d'avis
deux ouvriers les experts les troisièmes
alphonse alfonso un freluquet de la
havane dont elle a divorcé il lui lui
rapporta pour des millions de bijoux une
savante elle je ne sais plus
cet apport croire je vous pose la
question mais celle ci ont préjugé il
sans reproche est ce que je pouvais
raisonnablement vous laisser courir de
tels risques
à toi michel buisson demain chirurgien à
toi martine qui est belle comme le jour
et qui mérite à tes côtés
le plus beau garçon du monde est ce que
vous n'avez pas le devoir de vous mettre
en garde de ménager votre avenir
mettez vous à ma place imaginez que vous
ayez des enfants
oui heureux 1-2 pouvait se faire je vous
connais pas avec moi qu'il vaut mieux ne
pas voir blanc ce qui est rouge et pas
risquer de se dire après 30 à ma parole
mais mais lui il a des plumes ou et la
barre mais je ne m'en étais pas aperçu
et ghazi belle et la question de cinéma
jean françois blanchet
bonjour mauvaise humeur martin
mais qu'est-ce que là ça mène à rien ça
va très bien mais pourquoi cet accueil
martinez ce visage et se regardent
furieux que tu ais je fais je vous prie
monsieur de ne poser aucune question et
démontre aussi à différents égards que
je suis au vôtre qu'est-ce que tu l'as
fait je m'apprête à aller faire un tour
place ferrer j'ai pensé que j'aurais
peut être eu la chance de rencontrer
dont il fut me présenter à la question
du cinéma n'est pas bon
si jamais c'est une satire je serais
allé à neuilly ou à vaugirard un l'avion
atteindra varsovie évite la pologne
monsieur et vive la parole c'est une
blague
qu'est ce que nice matin elle est
nerveuse à moi j'ai pas monsieur je
dirais par le par trou noir à de pâles
et trocadéro rue pétrarque
tu comprends très bien est rien
société je comprends que vous trop
secrétaire et d'épouser un général à
elle fait de la fièvre
non du tout expliqué m mais pas françois
étaient sujettes à ces crises là bas
c'est la première fois mais ça va passer
et ça inquiète par toi de la tendance
avait ça pareil moi pourquoi au
contraire un petit peu tout de même
ou alors serait ce mois je me le demande
mais il nous devions aller déjeuner à
fontainebleau ma petite martine combien
de personnes attablées monsieur mais
nous deux mortes une cette question va
je n'avais pas michel alors moi je me
dépêche de ma vie dit j'espère j'essaie
de me faire mal et printanière je suis
ravie à l'idée d'aller faire un tour
dans la nature il s'est imposé dimanche
vous attend
personne vous en faites une fête cadeau
ça va pas vous non plus et vous très
bien et vient ni sais pas enfin nous
allons nous qu'est ce qu'on décide
j'hésitais entre une croisière une
simple promenade sur la scène en canot
pneumatique soucis physiques
oui commandant fabrica le palois ou
alors un week end au caire chez les b à
moins qu'un tour à laval ne soit tout
est dit est malade on va bien à petit ce
que tous les deux ça vous fera du bien
des fleurs pour moi parce que j'étais le
petit coffre en soit on déménage dans
votre famille il ya eu des cas déjà mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ces manières
michel je veux savoir qui je veux savoir
enfin pourquoi une croisière et pourquoi
place ferrer mais qu'est-ce qui vous
fasse de la place ferrer n'a fait ça va
pas non
pourquoi ne lui reprochera qui estime
par le dragueur pas de quoi pour bébé
excusez moi j'ai mon examen le 27
je vous tire marie véron excusez moi
s'est jamais autant c'est bien le maire
monsieur merci mes enfants à travailler
bien l'avenir vous le rendra bah vous
avez résolu et puis ça vous va bien les
féliciter vous pouvez vous donner raison
mais vous me permettez madame il ya des
enfants et moi oui mais bon on peut vous
mettre tous dans le même sac
non mais un tour la balle et bva ce
n'est pas demain qu'on me reverra dans
cette banque et il a discrètement ce pas
de te poser une question et tout si tu
veux tous amassé amis pour nous français
que vient de faire dans cette histoire
la comtesse polonaise et la caissière du
cinéma perret et pourquoi le style dans
la lah pourquoi le déjeuner fontaines
d'eau gelée et pourquoi l'institut de
bodélio ne parle pas ne défend pas je
sais ainsi tu as osé ton amitié pour moi
n'a pas suffi à te rendre ta raison
perdu tu en es là où vous dire que je
dis là c'est faire une enfant manque
plus que le double d'âge que tu as porté
sur les fonts baptismaux
enfin et qui de surcroît est mon enfant
oui la mesure que ça allait bien au-delà
elle est bien bonne toi me dire ça à moi
alors que toi mais j'écris je crée cinq
coups se compose je suis artiste et je
chante l'amoureuse le temps à moi ne
peut rien que me faire la politesse de
m'oublier dans sa besogne
il n'a pas de pression sur moi sur une
ville comme si nous avions le même un
nom on l'était olution ensemble à l'ange
mais c'est un argument clé je le
prendrai même pas la peine de martina
les maths il n'a rien à voir avec mon
histoire comment même si victor j'ai
raison d'avoir peur et tu arrêtes carte
cadeau d'avoir raison rôle d'un jacuzzi
les forces étaient aux portes à celle
des pirates avec jacques lafleur
allô allô des renseignements de la gare
de lyon est dit monsieur est ce que par
hasard le rapide de dijon qui devait
entrer en gare hier à 17h12 est bien
arrivé quand j ai pas de quoi rire il
est arrivé hier
merci monsieur
alo'o puis je prends des mre de
jacqueline assez vous je suis un ami de
libye hier françois ya thomas est ce que
par hasard vous envie de ses nouvelles
non mais parce que elle devait rentrer
de dijon et puis j'appelle chez elle on
ne répond pas elle nous a pas appelés en
plus à vous vous seriez très aimable
s'il vous plaît je ne bouge pas de chez
moi
merci le zinc
la poste je peux atteindre mon temps à
l'eau à la poste oui dites-moi est-ce
que par hasard vous auriez reçu un
télégramme pour le grand soir
maintenant quand morgane le grand prix
françois franchement halle aux grains
sous préfet
avenue victor hugo à ça tout ben non pas
comme c'est dimanche français marié
téléphoné le message et vous l'avez rien
merci monsieur e pardon il avance dans
ton travail
j'ai rien fait depuis trois ans la
petite n'est pas rentré de voyage les
idées me viennent et fils comme l'éclair
impossible de les rattraper et elle
m'avait dit samedi je ne sais pas ce qui
se passe ça ira mieux pour la petite
sera rentré bas
pour elle je tremble toujours pas vous
n'êtes pas fâché au moins aller comme au
projet touché puisque samsung
crois tu que c'est vrai on est dans
l'innocence et en fini demain mais c'est
charmant toutes ses naïvetés là et dites
moi bien qu'on amour guerre froide
savant turenne la nuit je dors très mal
je me réveille la vie que je me retourne
te laisse à ses rangs lieu quand la
petite sera rentré dans l'ordre et que
tu par hasard des thons rouges
précisément que j'en avais fait de
mettre un coup moins heureux
robin si tu savais ce qui m'arrive à moi
ce serait pas croire si ça n'était vrai
c'est à se demander s'il n'est pas tombé
sur la tête jeudi m'écouter armand vous
n'y pensez pas nous ne sommes plus en
pourquoi en 1937 là je peux pas vous
donner de détails il a mis trois heures
à me rappeler celle en affaires et donc
j'ai oublié de te dire qui c'est
qu'armand appartient à une excellente
famille organes des préfets des
armateurs des vicaires généraux
qu'est ce qui t'arrive et il est encore
à bien et l'hiver a déjà eu un pont
rouge à bâle-ville effet jeu de karim
haggui les faire pour son or aussi tu
voyais au volant de sa voiture au
s'énerve higuain semble donner quand je
suis de bonne compagnie qu'est ce que
vient m en face du te veux et le moins
ils venaient poser un il venait poussée
que le christ qu'il soit aussi jolie que
l'aurore c'est un peu raide en plus
alors que me consécutif
tu demandes à réfléchir tu as besoin de
mon autorisation aline amants sont
toujours un peu les enfants de leurs
grands fils au monarque
on est on n'est pas pressé tu es libre
avery a maintenant que je vais te dire
quelque chose
nous avons décidé de ne pas faire de
portel
à moitié non non non pas toi si tu veux
un cortège de radin pouvait alors sur la
pointe des pieds dans une sorte de
chuchotements ce ça charmant
si tu dis pas non a priori si tu veux
bien je vais penser ça mon chéri je te
dirai écoutez vous avez attendu trente
ans avant de faire votre demande
et bah attendait dont trois semaines
pour conclure a décidément tout le monde
est fou c'est merveilleux vd tu sais on
nous dit non ce soir où je nous nous
irons à prague dîner ou vache te le
dirai demain si dieu pourrait pas me
prêter un petit peu d'argent pour la
page vous a plu
non j'ai dépensé tout mon trimestre et
mon notaire ne veut plus rien savoir
il a besoin d'argent ah oui pour me
faire belle mais je te le rendent rêve
avant mada quand je serai riche demain
merci mon trésor droit au teich
antibactérien à monter j'ai bâti radin
allez hop c'est pas fini abbas faisait
mal vous ne quittez pas je l'appelle
michel michel téléphone
allô bonjour gens n'ont pas ce soir je
t'expliquerai oui mais avant samedi
parce que sa vie serait loin oui je te
dirai d'accord ce soir chez toi d'accord
au revoir
tu seras mon samedi aux intrus dans sa
chambre elle parvient compiègne quel
sujet va être pareil normale
c'est-à-dire gay tu m'en demande
beaucoup elle aussi depuis vision et n'a
pas desserré les dents
eh bien ça vaut mieux quelques fois
bonsoir mais michel je suis un ami pour
toi tu eu confiance en moi mon bonheur
de préoccupe bon travail ma santé des
malades
maintenant enfin monsieur je devine que
tu assures aequo avec moi heureux alors
moi non plus honda laisse filer on n'y
peut rien me gêne au aura pas
recommencer tourcoing déballage une
explication en copains on n'est pas
copain depuis vie jean tulard décourager
ces non sérieux puisque grâce à toi ça
ne l'est plus qui doit être content même
si c'était sérieux mais tu l'aimés tu
parti on a droit ça nous autres aimé une
femme calcul de son âge et une grue en
plus un à mon père même je n'ai jamais
dit ça pardon tu l'as dis moi j'étais
moins compliqué je me posais pas de
questions
j'étais largement payé par mon bonheur
le premier le vrai que j'ai connu c'est
ça que tu voulais savoir
ben oui j'étais le russe et où est son
âge n'avait aucune importance si ces
amendes même si elles étaient sincères
et même le travail ne me coûtait rien
simplement parce que j'étais heureux ça
t'es pas peut-être mais je leur ai
décroché mon internat avec elle rien de
qui tu es pourquoi ne pas m'avoir dit
quoi bon vous êtes tous pareils
michel jetons père n'est pas tout le
monde sait ça console noire parce que tu
m'as dit sur elle soit logique entre
nous tu sais mieux que moi c'est pas
chouette et mais si c'est chouette je
pense que c'est chouette
même si à nantes mais le cnjc bêtise le
temps passe naturellement michel non
leur pourra pas besoin de regarder en
arrière
ce soit pas le moment les fonds même si
elle n'en du moment qu'on croit à tous
autres
d'autant plus qu'il peut leur arriver de
ne pas mentir c'est rare mais ça peut
arriver
alors tu ne l'a pas revue soit content
tu as gagné tu parles d'une victoire à
ce prix là n'a pas rappelé j'ai
raccroché
tu crois pas que j'allais supplier à
genoux une femme qui se payer ma tête
avec les égyptiens
d'ailleurs j'ai pris une décision
irrévocable à laquelle tu t'attends pas
avant dimanche je serai loués ou vendus
au kenya je vais rejoindre un camarade
étoiles examen le 27
on a eu des mois l'examen tu sais tu vas
pas briser ton avenir sur un coup de
tête et aérostier au kenya alors que tu
n'as 15 unis à faire pour qu'elle soit
là à tes pieds ou ailleurs un phénomène
mais ne demandent qu'à revenir s'est
courue elle aille au caire pourquoi
loquet je suis par ghazi moi tu sais
voici en résumé europe
c'était un oriental ça n'a rien à voir
car c'est trop tard enfin tu vas pas
aller au kenya michel tu prends l'avion
battant la france samedi
j'ai retenu ma place dès qu'il aura
trouvé un emploi l'a battu le racing
oui j'étais promis
en attendant je vais les passer à moi à
nice dans une maison de repos on est
vraiment besoin à dix mois avant mais tu
peux apporter mais bien sûr on est jeune
on peut souffrir sera pitois personnes
on est fait pour ça c'est pas grave
bah pas bon quand on est malheureux
c'est toujours grave c'était sérieux toi
aussi ça de manga va penneteau regarde
pas je suis tombé ça n'a rien à voir
mais apple n'est pas un étranger pour
ses enfants quelques fois la preuve
c'est que tu n'as rien compris comment
je reviens comprise tuer mais toi aussi
non mais ça va pas vraiment bien de
tomber du ciel mais je t'aime pas toi
les lie enfin me tue les maîtres de
quelle manière il est donc des manières
d'aimer
où en êtes-vous tous les deux ont passé
grâce à toi tu peux quand même pas m'en
vouloir si je rêvais pourquoi d'un homme
jeune sportif et travailleurs dans la
cheminée pour noël non mais laisse moi
rire tu es plutôt que c'est que ça
t'embête que jacques grange michel
bouquet
non mais je m'arrangerais comment warin
ici tout seul centre sans vous devez
vous avez pensé qu'ils feraient tavini
l'annoncé la même mais tu dises à mansle
et des poids lourds pour toi on sait
bien mais vous allez crever de chaleur
ou kelly appli pc pour le cas
5 euros boeing ainsi c'est décidé c'est
décidé non elle ne renierait pas
approchez approchez mais plus près enfin
bon je vous ai vu naître nous non un jeu
que vous pensez que je suis heureux mois
sans nouvelles comme vous alors qu
auprès d'elle j'ai exactement votre âge
un panel et cet été enfin un voyage tous
les trois ensemble dont on misera nos
peines ça va ça va
[Musique]
billy talent pourquoi m'as-tu les
saisons et igor froid que je devais
quitter dijon hier comme prévu une
occasion s'est présentée de rentrer par
la roue tourne a eu une panne impossible
de téléphoner par la route avec une
vieille dame rassure toi je le jure
c'est la vérité on ne jure pour les
mensonges et seulement tu pouvais
imaginer ce que j'ai pu être pas des
idées et il ya travaillé non impossible
mais je vais à papéa j'étais manqué un
coup parfait tous us en projets et les
enfants alors là oui justement
majorettes à parler ils veulent partir
pour le kenya
michel décident de s'expatrier martin de
le rejoindre
bien entendu je me propose à ce projet
insensé
je suis responsable de leur avenir ils
leur appartiennent à venir à toi le
tiens moi le bien mais nous autres
vivier nous sommes libres bae a eu ce
différend
mais pareil ce qu'ils affirment ils ont
raison et s'ils sont heureux
je finis par croire qu'ils ne l'étaient
alors michel buchet martin n'avait
jamais été aussi des comme toi quand je
suis laïc comme moi 38
c'est vrai les v alors alors bonjour
madame ou mademoiselle en bas je suis
pas fâché de mouvoir sans vous françois
est éperdument
n'est ce pas mon chien ont sûrement dit
dans un propos moi je peux pas y arriver
puis c'est avec le petit peu d'argent
qui
faut faire un petit effort
donne-moi 50 50 x 50 mm
toi tu changeras jamais voir c'est la
grâce que demande en ciel qui hélas ne
coûtera pas toujours
c'est pourquoi attendre après les
terribles
charme 06 la demoiselle des examens et
monfils à miss paris l'on vous aimez moi
j'ai pu mal que vous en faire date et
enfin moi je ne suis que sa mère
en tout cas ne mangent pas tous non non
non pas et ne rentrent pas trop tard
nana qui permet jusqu'à une heure pas
davantage mettons trois aires suivront
parce qu'ils sont gentils d'où les deux
eaux
c'est vrai on va te laisses aller voilà
dix francs pour aller vous êtes mort
elle a retrouvé un ancien ennemi figure
encore très bien très bien et je
souhaite d'être aussi jeune quand joël
son âge pas toi ma mère qui se remet à
faire la fête pas d'âge pour l'amour
tout de même mais c'est merveilleux
france va alors qu'est ce que tu as
raconté aux enfants âgés ainsi nuit que
thérèse était une femme dangereuse
infidèle cruel et que cadeaux mené trois
liaisons à la fois pour les dégoûter du
confort et tu as réussi trois bien
j'aurais peur c'est à dire depuis huit
jours tout est rompu entre eux par ta
phu pour l'heure bien évidemment le choc
a été rude mais c'est une affaire
d'habitude du typhon tutti frais toi vas
par mois cette question qu'est ce que tu
vas chercher
michel matuidi n'a pas revu thérèse
depuis huit jours c'est cela quel est
son numéro le 966 83 ans pourquoi et
cadeaux va venir pourra faire mais je
m'attends à le trouver dans les pires
disposition à sa place je suis tu fais
allô allô les 906 83 rose bonjour ici
lit très bien merci vous même non non
non non je rentre de voyage c'est faux
pas de oui oui dites moi madame je suis
chargé d'une commission serait très
importante pour vous françois besoin
urgent de vous rencontrer
oui c'est très important bah oui en
voisine dias bien sûr oui oui vous
attend en s'il vous plaît madame mais
c'est vous qui êtes tout à fait charmant
je vous en prie donc voir mais pourquoi
la faire venir j'ai rien à lui dire main
il t'appartient de réparer et de lui
expliquer doit également pourquoi michel
a cessé de la voix enfin jean ray
bonneville de lui raconter tout ce que
j'ai dit sur elle les pires jambes
pas ma vie j'ai les répéter tu te
débrouilles ira ce qui compte c'est
l'avenir de michel que tu le gardes près
de toi qui soit heureux
martin aussi or il ne s'agit peut-être
que d'une crise passagère d'un caprice
d'enfant qui n'a pas le droit de former
les cas même le devoir de le favoriser
discrètement dans la mesure où leur
gaieté leur santé leur travail ne leur
enthousiasme le sont en jeu pour moi
françois je t'aime moi je sais et cie
qui même toit mais pourquoi pourquoi
brave ventes et des histoires pareilles
pourquoi alors avoir gâché leur idéal
même si ce n'est pas le tien et pourquoi
après tout n'aurait-il pas droit à ce
bonheur qu'ils sont à raison de nous
envier mais qui te dit que thérèse n'est
pas sincère et michel est un garçon
intelligent
quant à cadeaux je le crois délicat
autant que tu l'aies avec moi et et
martin est une jeune fille adorable
l'espère la vie je les aime moi des
enfants eux ne m'aiment pas beaucoup je
sais ils sont jaloux de moi même mais ça
s'arrangera et je finirai bien par les
gagner
quelle idée d'avoir inventé des
histoires pas
mon amour bonsoir monsieur bonsoir à toi
et toi et moi françois je voudrais
m'entretenir quelques instants avec toi
je ne sais pas ce que tu es à venir mais
tu peux parler devant tel nom reste ça
ne te gêne pas si mal moselle et dans le
secret elle
d'ailleurs je serais bref prends ton
temps c'est dimanche
alors mon vieux alors voilà françois je
te vois toute la vérité
il n'a pas dépendu de ma volonté mais
j'ai demandé circonstances comme
bouleversement imprévu se soit produit
dans ma vie je ne m'y attendais pas je
ne le souhaitait pas j'ai essayé de
l'éviter
ce que je tiens dans tous les cas tu
dire c'est que j'ai toujours respecté
martineau j'étais sûr là tu été
imprudent je connais ta loyauté en la
circonstance elle a été totale voilà je
pense que je me suis expliquée
clairement j'ai compris a été gagnée
propos que des bêtises - martin à
l'affreux portrait oui il fallait
tailler dans le vif qui a réussi mais
non j'ai pas réussi c'est un truc en soi
jetons alors voilà je vous l'avais
promis une austin et bien elle et l'a
emmené au jardin elle était une fin mais
ça guérit tu as gagné françois mais
c'est mieux pour elle est ce mieux pour
toi peut-être pas pour moi voilà
maintenant on en parle plus jamais comme
un soir chez moi tu me jouera confine
alj espère que nous décrocherons un
succès je le souhaite pour vous-même
moselle car vous êtes très sympathique
entre nous tu as plus de chances que moi
françois j'étais peut-être encore un
parti très possible qui sait je peux
ajouter à vos monsieur khadir je vous en
prie vous me promettez de me croire
malgré mon âge et vous voudrez bien
pardonner mon indiscrétions martin vous
adore elle n'est pas plus raisonnable
que moi aujourd'hui soir
merci d'être venus je compte sur toi
françois on demande souvent chers amis
je viens me faisait bien malgré la
france malgré le franc ne jouez pas les
benêts le grand même si le rôle vous va
bien mon résumé non non j'aime trop la
vie pour me l'a gâchée malheureusement
les autres s'en chargent pas moi
j'espère excusez moi mais c'est cadeau
mais vous et moi le connaissons fort peu
n'est ce pas alors débrouiller vos
affaires et laissez moi m'occuper des
miennes vous
eh bien je suis là comme le ton juste
puis-je savoir à quelle fin je suis
convoqué l'ad'abord charmilles permettez
moi de vous remercier d'avoir répondu à
mon appel en oui c'est très aimable
valider sa part quoi d'autre soyaux de
charmantes ça vous va si bien
sarkozy faire je vous écoute le grand
j'espère que je ne suis pas trop si vous
êtes là
eh bien vous vous aimez michel c'est un
interrogatoire
une simple question michel est un garçon
charmant avec qui je m'accorde bien il
est jeune il a 20 ans il est en pleine
forme a évidemment il a encore des tas
de choses à apprendre mais quoi ces
lâches si je comprends bien il vous
plait quand un garçon est charmant et
sympathique et puis à tout le monde mais
la une les deux femmes n'ont et son
drôle mais lui il vous aime vous voulez
des détails
vous étiez heureux tous les deux mois le
bonheur je le gagne on me le rend ou pas
ensuite pourquoi cette rupture qui
m'inquiète
non mais vous en avez de bonnes legrand
pourquoi cette rupture après le paquet
michel m'a envoyé deux jeunes europe à
moi non je me tiens droite je n'accroche
à personne je fais ce qu'il me plaît
quand il me plaît c'est pas toujours
commode à moissy mais évidemment belle
comme vous voulez joël flatter suppose
j'ai dû faire quelque chose
en tout cas pas si le billet que michel
m'a envoyé madame vous en avez enterré
trois je ne serai pas de 4 milliards
et si ghazi s'est fait photographier
sous son fait à votre bras sur les
marches de la madeleine et qu'il vous
plaise d'aller rejoindre alfonso à la
havane pour y récupérer vos bijoux
je vous informe que je n'ai pas moi
d'usiné levallois et que je ne travaille
pas dans le caoutchouc synthétique
douloureusement à vous en souvenir de
nos bacchanales non mais qu'est ce que
vous dites de cette littérature à moi
veut épouser dans la bonne de la
polonaise et prenez un abonnement au
cinéma perret où l'on vous attend à la
caisse cela vous distraire entre 2 bat
nadal a eu ou à vaugirard et même un
voyage à athènes en compagnie de votre
secrétaire la vie est courte
à votre âge surtout à vous avez mille
fois raison d'en profiter
dommage je vous aimais martin voilà ce
qu'ont écrit à moi même pas en vue
mais ben quoi c'est plate belle tout à
l'heure vous vous indignez je suis une
femme monsieur cadeau vous êtes même une
date j'ose croire et une dame qui veut
doit la vérité précisément là nous voilà
qui s'apprête à mentir
quelle vérité le grand ci voit le couple
ou c'est moi qui ai inventé tout ses
espoirs
j'ai cru bien faire en faisant le mal
j'avais peur madame mais de quoi
mais de vous de votre char du danger que
pourrait michel qui avait complètement
perdu la tête
vous êtes belle madame et lui et ce en
f1 au détrompez-vous il attaquait fort
bien et le mal le mal un mal qui donne
tout de même un peu de plaisir je
m'excuse de techno quoi aujourd'hui je
reconnais mon erreur
sincèrement je la regrette pas c'est un
père qui vous parle
le kenyane kenya michel doit partir
samedi pour le terrain
vous seul pouvez leur péché de faire ça
plus mais qu'est ce que c'est encore que
cette histoire de kenyans c'est au
diable je vous expliquerai non je vous
en prie je reconnais qu'à dont je suis
allé en amérique
le bonheur de michel ne dépend que de
vous son avenir ses études avec vous il
peut tout sans vous rien il n'a tout de
même prix vous en avez enterré trois je
ne serais pas capable
c'est un détail un peu gros et au détail
mais puisque c'est moi qui les ai
inventées mais gardait jusqu'à son
internat seulement pour son père mais je
ne fais pas les intérims mois legrand
je suis pas une caissière que préoccupe
les échéances je tenais je prends mais
pas jusqu'à te le fait pas l'amour avec
l'année sur le calendrier mois jusqu'à
son internat nan mais c'est un monde
on vient me dire à moi ce sera fini
après l'oral même si j'ai les poils
avance à l'écrit
jega fait pas un peu je suggérais michel
à 20 ans et moins 35 après world sa et
même si c'était trop ça me va bien tous
les deux vous allez bonne mine avec vos
histoires d'agen d'or ce jusqu'à leur
halo ou non bon je sais bien je ne me
fais pas d'illusions et demain n'est pas
aujourd'hui ça vous ne me prenez rien et
les rêves ne se répètent guerre il faut
en changer pour tenir mais je suis
entraîné croyez - et puis ce qu'il vous
faut une réponse le grand voici la
mienne pas jusqu'à la terre n'a pas de
limite pas de mesures par prudence
j'aime trop l'amour pour le fond si on
me dépose pas après l'oral moi je quitte
avant les cris et s'il le faut je paye
le prix non quel dommage ça arrangerait
tout moi-même chère madame je suis sans
illusion
soignez vos complexes et laissez moi les
miens et d'ailleurs je n'en ai pas mais
permettez je dis aux côtes
rien ne s'arrange et j'ai tout expliqué
aux enfants françois beau mensonge et
vous ressenti une sont déchaînés contre
-2 chesnais et terriblement malheureux
et c'est par désespoir plus forte pour
le kenya aussi les bonheurs ne sont pas
réciproque danser dans cette maison je
n'accepterai pas que soient refusés à
vos enfants les joies que nous accordons
le coin qu'il puisse m'en coûter tout va
au royal va s'étaler ensemble qu'il faut
prendre laisser aux parts donnez moi ce
n'est pas du chantage
de quoi je me mêle mais c'est naturel
vous êtes leur mère à temps
et peut-être jamais mais quelle mère est
formidable alors que faisons nous maman
maman
maman se faire du mal à m'y faire
votre décision françois et bien vous
venez avec nous madame je suis très
occupé ce soir je réfléchiront sans père
tout aléa les toitures est je suis très
occupé cet argent réfléchir et papa
cinéma j'aurais beaucoup de mal à les
faire
j'avais dit que je leur ferai signe si
nous étions d'accord je peux sans regret
c'est ce qu'on m'a raconté son toit fait
défaut c'était lui qui avait tout
inventé
didon apparente avoir osé dire ça
thérèse à ton âge
machiavel me machiavel à son père alors
vous m'avez phare de l'été reste on va
la musique qui me répondre à cela et
bien oui
je vous présente armand mon arme
mon fiancé monsieur j'ai l'honneur de
vous demander la main de mignot jeunes
de madame votre mère monsieur g vous la
corde
merci mon fils mon fils avait décidément
j'aurais énormément de mails avaient
fait nous sourira maine-et-loire
l'histoire et des rats
[Musique]
la pièce que nous avons eu la joie de
jouer devant vous et de roger ferdinand
la musique de georges auric
les paroles de chansons et la mise en
scène de robert manuel
décors sont de roger ap
quant à mes camarades on commence à en
voir le bout là bas
nadine alari
jean-pierre parliez
par isis
renée lester lee
marie-claude mestral
nathalie baye
marcel charest
à sétif
[Musique]